hello everybody
welcome back to the speed chess
championship grand master robert hess
alongside me today
is my good friend my partner grandmaster
daniel nardiski
dania are you ready for what will
undoubtedly be
an epic match up in the quarterfinals of
the 2020scc
hello robert good to see everybody good
to be here i could not think of a better
way to start
uh the morning on my end than this
absolutely epic
speed chess championship match between
wesley so and yon shishtoff duda
i don't know any other words to say this
is going to be epic i i can feel it in
my bones
well i believe that judah has a lot of
work cut out for him because
in previous iterations of the sec they
have gone
head to head and it was wesley show's
taking in that match however
duda is a new player he's improved in
the last couple years
so what do you think you play these guys
more than anybody
yeah duda has definitely improved i've
i've had a lot of experience playing
both of them and
in blitz and in the case of wesleyan
classical they're both
absolute monsters they're a joy to watch
uh
and they're both so universal and it is
important to point out that duda has
really really
improved in the shorter time controls
robert he is going to be a force to be
reckoned with
in the three-minute portion but
particularly in the bullet
that might be the match deciding portion
but we'll obviously have to see so
it might be a tale of improvement but
wesley is a stalwart
he certainly is and while you're talking
about time controls let's remind
everybody of the format for these
speeches championship matchups
as you see on the screen in front of you
that there will be an
hour and a half of five minute plus one
second increment blitz
followed by a full hour of the three
plus one
and then we get down to the 30 minutes
of bullet that's what daniel was
highlighting saying
that's where young christoph duda has
his biggest advantage
and we'll need to see if he can keep
that up against someone who is as strong
as wesley so of course
if there is a tie we get into the tie
breaks of the
mini match four games at one plus one
and donya
of course when these top players face
off they just want to crush
an elite opponent but there's quite a
lot of prize money at stake
and in round two the winner gets a cool
three grand
in addition to splitting the other three
grand based on win percentage so
a lot of money out at play here i'm i'm
looking at these prizes these are these
are mouth-watering and uh of course we
should point out that
even when the match is decided there's
uh quite a bit
left to be decided by the actual outcome
of the game so
there's pride on the line uh there is a
lot of money on the line and
this just adds to the suspense and the
excitement but just because of the
players themselves uh we get a big
portion of the
of the excitement that comes with these
matches certainly the case
and you know not only are these players
playing for quite a prize fund
that everybody who's watching can get
involved and try to win some cash
guess the move right you want to bust
the move guess the move and
there have been some repeat winners that
i've noticed in
some of these matches but you can get
involved by
going to chess.com live trying to your
hand
and guessing the correct moves of the
players make them and the top three
premium gestures won cash prizes well
if you're not premium member you can win
some premium memberships it's a great
opportunity to
test your hand at playing like some of
the world's best while having the
incentive to win
some cool hard cash robert i'm looking
at the bracket here who are these
weak players
yeah could they have found anybody
stronger but in all seriousness
this is incredible look at all of these
players mvl
aronian uh chess.com could not have
assembled a more elite squad of
uh blitz bullet and of course classical
players this is awesome
well before we get to this specific
matchup dania while i have you i have to
ask
look at his bracket real quick and i'm
going to make you
pick the winners of this matchup this is
this round except me robert
this round pick your winners at this
round i really miss commentating with
you
i was thinking that until you asked me
to make the prediction but i guess
i have to stay true to my nickname well
we have the probability at 57 percent
for
wesley i think it's going to be a close
match i think it's going to come down to
the bullet
but i think with duda's recent
improvement in the bullet section
i have a feeling that he might make a
statement in that final section
now this is absolutely no disrespect to
my boy wesley i have
tremendous respect for him he is he's a
monster
there's just no other way to say it i
think this is going to be a very close
match but
judah's recent improvement that might be
uh the game deciding phenomenon we'll
see
well you know you're mentioning it we
have the smarter chess predictions i
have to fight those typically but right
now i'm
more or less in agreement with it i am
sort of upset
hearing myself say those words but look
at wesley so's blitz rating he's above 3
and let's be real you add the increment
to the clock he's even stronger
but to jkd's credit he was
really a force against fabiano caruana
he started off slowly he was down three
games to none
and you know while i had the call i was
kind of like wait are these predictions
can they be real
dude is in big trouble then he went off
and won four straight games to close
that the longest time control
before being completely dominant in the
shortest time patrol
he beat fabiano caruana eight games to
one
in bullets oh that is that is incredible
now fabi of course
is known for his playing longer time
controls but let's let's be
real 8-1 against a player this elite in
any time control is
uh a an achievement to be very proud of
and i have a feeling robert that the
reason you
seem to imply that you're going with
wesley here i don't think it's because
of the smarter chess predictions i think
it's because i
called it for duda if i'd called it for
wesley i have a feeling you would have
cited against the smarter chess
predictions you know donya
i i think i'm very agreeable and
i'll remove my arrow because i was
having some fun on the analysis board
just before
but i you know i don't want to go
against you you're my friend we get
along well i always enjoy
commentating with you but i think we
have to give based on the history and
speed chess championship
and just how strong wesley so is and i
think
one of the best parts about wesley is it
doesn't feel like he's
tiltable in the same way others are he
is a stoic
player and his style i think is one that
doesn't allow him
to fully tilt now i will say that if he
is facing a deficit
i don't always believe that his style
helps him mount a comeback because it's
a very precise style he's not taking as
much risk as other players
but if he starts out in the lead good
luck taking him down
he's a boa constrictor he he's so
universal he can play a lot of different
openings so i
i agree with you i think the sort of one
could cite the lack of this kind of
absolute uncompromising play but
the flip side of that is is that he can
play any type of position he calculates
incredibly well and as you said he
almost never tilts
he's so calm he's so experienced and for
that matter duda is
uh to some degree as well i really
haven't seen him
had that you know explosive tilt uh
either so
uh we'll see if if either player manages
to jump out uh to a big lead
at the start but as we saw in the
caruana match anything can be surmounted
in the sec
for sure and we will be able to see the
action unfold in just a second the
players
getting situated you see jkd stretching
and
we are off the games are officially
underway
wesley so starts with the white pieces
we get a sicilian
diana i'm zero percent surprised about
the opening because i just saw
young christophe duda use this against
fabiano caruana
game after game and i remember jkd
playing this
uh as far back as i remember how the
under 18 world youth i think the under
when i was playing the under 14 i think
he might have been playing the under 10
and he was already playing the night or
this guy is an expert in the truest
sense of the word in the night or but
knight c6 now am i hallucinating or is
this a very uncommon way to develop the
knight in the night or
yeah and i think knight a5 this i have
not seen
i guess the knight's going to c4 well if
you allow me my knight will gladly hop
right in here with the bishop's defense
and actually he'll
he'd like to see maybe knight c4 knight
c5 i've seen that's an old school idea
exploiting that pin against the d6 pawn
to situate the knight on c5
right you're saying that there is a
queen in line with the rook so the rook
wins that battle most of the time so
knight c5
is possible here but duda goes for it
anyway and
danya i think this goes to show that
allowing a capture on e6 and replacing
with a pawn
that's typically not the biggest deal
because you're trying to fight
tooth and nail for that d5 square right
exactly that plays right into blacks and
it's important to recognize the rules
for determining pawn structures in the
night or
as you hinted at robert are completely
different you're fighting really over
squares here and it's not about the
aesthetic appeal
of your pawns and that's why we see
wesley sliding his bishop away
the fight over the d5 square is on
and don't i have to say that i like the
knight of c4 a lot better than i would
if it were on d7 i'm just going to drag
the piece
over the square which is where it goes
often you go knight d7
you bring a rook to c8 you bring your
bishop to e7 very
calm sort of natural developing moves no
huge risk in the early stages
but i like this knight on c4 because
watch out for a potential
sacrifice on b2 of course not right now
you have to line up some pressure on the
knight on c3 with the rook on c
and all that good stuff but i see a
knight on c4 i i just
store that information knight takes b2
at some point
may be a possibility maybe slide the
queen away to e1 and try to capture that
knight before it
wreaks any havoc on the position because
if you play queen f2 here you might
come under some knight take c4 business
instead wesley sliding his king over so
rook c8 the kind of move that would be
conducive to
an idea that you mentioned robert but i
feel like wesley's holding this in store
uh the idea of of going queen e1
and taking on c4 knight takes c4 here
needs to be calculated
no it doesn't work because of queen e4
so duda does put something on the c file
yeah i actually want to bring up the
analysis board and show what dania was
talking about
it's a very good point when you see a
bishop like here
in line with another bishop right these
bishops are staring each other down
you have to watch out for tactics so for
example if this uh
queen went to f2 at some point let's say
here
you have to just look is there a knight
g4 type of move opening up the bishop's
attack on one another
and hitting the queen on f2 so those
ideas
are all in the air and diana pointed out
correctly instead we saw queen e1 which
was donnie's move and taking on c4 let
me ask you
now the b file is open how much do you
like the fact that you were able to take
this knight off the board
yeah i don't know i mean one of white's
classical ideas here it's called knight
d2 knight f1 knight
e3 but i also want a filet mignon steak
from ruth's chris steakhouse right now
and i'm not gonna get it so
dude i might have something to say about
this by putting a rook on b8 and maybe a
queen on b7
uh and the the issue is that wesley has
to be very careful about how he defends
the b2 pawn if he goes b3
dude is going to sack on b3 and
checkmate him maybe he wants to drop his
bishop back to c1 but that entails it's
that that has its own problems maybe d5
uh this gets very double-edged yeah and
yeah i saw the eval bar just
jump in dude his favor and we'll like
just sit on the position for a moment
here we'll
kind of think about it from a broader
point of view and
daniel this knight went to f1 like you
said trying to get to e3
into this d5 square if we talk about
ideal strategy
white would love to take on f6 and then
immediately put this knight on
to the d5 square and play knight against
bishop you often hear bishops are better
than knights
but not when the knight has a clear
outpost and a knight on d5
against a dark square bishop means that
the knight is going to be the superior
piece but that is
several moves away and as you just
pointed out dania moves like queen to b7
and then maybe even an eventual d5 you
always have to be on the lookout for
this d5 move it's critical
in the sicilian and if this bishop can
land on a3 to increase the pressure down
the b
file that would be a big problem right
and
duda realizes that the d5 square is in
everything because even if wesley
positions a knight
on d5 say knight e to d5 and duda takes
it with his knight he's gonna have the
idea of going bishop to g5
trying to distract that bishop on c1
from its
critical role that bishop on c1 it's
like atlas it's holding the world on its
shoulders
and if judah can distract it that could
lead to some major problems with the b2
pawn so i would consider knight t7 in
this position
uh trying to include the knight in the
attack maybe also 98 knight c7
but opening up that line of negotiation
between the dark square bishop and the
g5 square instead
due to going full on frontal assault
getting the rook to b6 all right yeah
this is a he makes his intentions very
clear
i'm tripling i am going to sack on b2 if
you allow me for mate
and a big issue as you highlighted
earlier is b3 is
not a possibility for white because you
do have two pawns protecting the square
but i also have a bishop in prime
location to just sacrifice itself on b3
so
when i play rook b6 you'll have to find
another way to defend
b2 and knight a4 will not satisfy
white's position because after rook b6
also have rook to b4 just trying to kick
this knight out so
already i believe wesley's in for a
tough decision he plays knight into d5
but what if you just capture it like you
said and then swing a rook to b6 and try
to get that
g5 well i guess maybe he wants bishop
takes d5 ed
and then rook b6 he wants to take on c4
so duda keeping the tension instead with
bishop to d8
um okay so i guess what if wesley plays
g5 here or something to that effect i i
think
i'm trying to figure out i'm trying to
get a pulse on the position what does
dude want to do maybe he just wants to
leave the knight on d5 entirely just go
knight d7
that's that's i don't know an idea you
mentioned before and well wesley doesn't
allow it to begin with
but knight d5 is met by bishop g5 you
pointed out this idea earlier
yeah but maybe on the other hand rook b6
is going to be met with queen c3 he goes
queen c3 preemptively
but that queen could also be a sitting
duck if let's say bishop could land on
a5
and that square could be supported
somehow so maybe queen b5 and bishop d a
bishop a5 something like that
it's a bit of a trek to make this all
work but it's good to think in these
terms of
how do i improve my bishop or the bishop
one of six staring into its own pawn
the best move for black is pawn e5
thrown off board
and then that's that yeah if only we
could imagine how much that would change
chess
you just said hate one of your own
pieces let's get that out the way
because my bishop on f6
or bishop takes e5 that would be a great
move well isn't that a new variant
you can capture i was gonna say i think
i heard about that uh and but you could
also do that over the
over the board just kind of pretending
you know i'm doing you a favor
for god's sake i'm taking my own pieces
now wow c3 here
is a very tempting move but then wesley
could play b3
and uh that pawn on b3 is significantly
more solid than it would be with a pawn
on
c4 right this is really heating i mean
this is just like a pressure cooker in
here it doesn't seem like that much is
happening
but the stakes are incredibly high for
both sides
in this position you're mentioning
pressure cookers you're mentioning
steaks
are you hungry danya like what's going
on here no i got some granola here and
some coffee you don't have to worry
about me uh
robert i got all the best uh food that
the bay area has to offer
i i worry because i care done just so
you know
i i know you i care about you too robert
just as we look at this incredibly tense
position i i need to waste everyone's
time and just say this
robert needs that uh words of
affirmation those are important
indeed and finally a knight on d5 he
needed it because otherwise that bishop
was coming to c5 where
the queen gets strapped over here okay
so can do to get his bishop
to one of these golden squares b4 oh and
if he moves it by the way
97 check has to be reckoned with that's
a fork and then d6 is going to topple
look at the time also 30 seconds i feel
like duda has let's go maybe rook c4
tries to get his a pawn in motion
wesley's position not easy either it's
not clear how to make progress here
do you like that what's pawn a4 i like
that rook c4 idea as well because you're
trying to trap the queen but the d6 pawn
will be hanging so also dude down to 30
seconds as well as he's been playing
you can't win good positions if we
consider his position good now
without time on the clock and down to 27
seconds and now he's
sort of on the defensive right donna he
put his rooks on the c file
where they're not barreling through
they're just protecting the pawn that's
gone too far
yes and h6 he hasn't forgotten about the
idea of bishop g5 wesley could drop his
knight back at some point and go after
the d6 but i wouldn't do that yet i
would try to make more improvements to
my position
but that's very hard to do in this in
this atmosphere maybe bishop e3 queen c1
try to retool your pieces the problem is
if you fall asleep due to plays a4 and
then the attack has
is reinvigorated so it's it's a very
hard environment to make any sorts of
improvements
uh the players are at a standstill here
h3 king h7 both trying to make
small improvements in the position and
wesley strikes with a four so
i like k7 for the end game but f4 is
dangerous because if some pieces get
traded off i look at that e4 pawn
it's isolated it can be attacked but for
now before
here comes the uh d6 uh pawn is
weak and the versus the d-file who's
this easier to play
for i have no idea actually have no idea
i think
on one hand black because black can make
the attacking moves but his position is
kind of collapsing too he's got eight
seconds gotta move a4 maybe just to
add some tabasco sauce to that queen
side he does it he gives up the b-force
but bishop b7 by wesley
maybe to take some pieces off the board
while he has a chance the problem is the
a-file though if it gets opened
duda can double on that file and deliver
a lobster pincer mate sort of on a1
yeah that's a good call and you can't
take on a4 like you would in other
variations because the bishop is now
under attacking queen b4
offering the queen trade just sliding
the queen back watch out for a b
bishop d5 rook b6 all these type of
attacking moves
and look at the clock wesley under 15
seconds
now retreating moves a b and rook a8
he's got something to the a file
yeah he's he nervously plays bishop five
and tri okay okay
eight queen oh we need two queen 255 g5
that's gonna be he does this first still
93 back but queen a2 for sure wesley and
the last he's got to move two seconds
oh my god he attacks the knight first
trying to get it out bishop d4 they'll
be queen eighteen twenty two playing
with a three bishop e3
oh it was amazing oh my goodness
wesley's a
devil is there three is gonna move he
wants he wants to take but the king runs
away
and bishop three does nothing just take
it rookie three oh
okay queen c7 watch out for h2 he's not
over here
it almost works h5 he wants to play h5
and up and up oh i don't like that movie
i don't like e5 and a lot of lights
battery f4 dude i had also
but this is looking good for black all
of a sudden take a g4 oh you can't go
he's not doing it he's got zero he's how
do we get the move off
i don't understand this is unbelievable
action to this first game queen
266 battery back up e6 opens it up
that's correct but now
dude has stabilized it and don't blunder
g7 with me right that's the only thing
and black despite being down a pawn
is better queen d6 and h4 i agree with
oh but he allowed g6 now that's a
okay finally an end game of course who's
better white seven pawn though
no pawn take on g6 now activity for
black rock h7 life looks
might be winning rook g2 mission b3 and
then f2 check oh
okay he's got to get a spawn in motion
how do you get the 55 defending c6
wesley's got to push it
okay rooks he never works he doesn't
work register's only moved
to rookie it is not possible wesley's
got to make a move that is huge he wins
the pawn
and now blacks are pumping this might be
a draw though
g2 i feel like we're auctioneers here
and then right now as well
what happened it's going to be a split
king e3 and
how do you make a fortress well either
side could still blunder a bishop
or move the bishop accidentally g6 judo
is going to try
to win this he's going to try to get his
rook to the other side of the board
robert
he's going to try to deliver a side
check and get that kink pry it away from
the bishop but it's not easy to do that
don't get made it
bishop d4 was almost made but that's why
i think wesley's been really smart but
putting his king on f4 that way wherever
the rook goes the king goes to the
opposite side
let me tell you their hands are shake
mine are and there's r too
when you're moving the mouse it's like
you don't want a mouse slip here you
know it looks like i'm getting super red
uh looking at this game but i think that
just my camera is doing funny things so
i'm pretty calm right now honestly i've
been enjoying the action
i'm feeling really at home in my chair
though this is
this is amazing and let's not forget
this is the first
game we could not have asked for a
better opening salvo to this uh to this
incredible
match and they're still going i mean
they're trying to you know posturing
here but
realistically black just doesn't have
any attempts even
the defense is very easy with that
increment particularly but i think that
jkd is smart to play this on we talk
about how in the bullet portion
that's where he has his best chances
he's also up a pawn so even if this were
a classical game
why not play it on he's a bishop yeah
the bishop on h5
is defended and defends everything
there's no risk okay they finally
mentioned
but yeah and people shouldn't dismiss
this and ah you know he's just being
obnoxious no he's not he's wearing
wesley dowd
he's forcing him to find all these
defensive moves uh and he's
as you said uh the shorter the time
control i think the more it favors duda
and in the second game we see
the players taking a breath time for a
petrov not that it's a peaceful opening
the petrov can explode
yeah um i would i would say that from
that first game as i'm reflecting on it
before we get into the the middle of
this one with the petrov
and pieces traded off but i will say
that westley
put amazing defense together and for
jan kristoff in time trouble the fact
that he was able to
get what looked like an attack he
couldn't quite handle it he didn't
put it together perfectly but his mouth
speed was there so that bodes well for
his chances come bullet time
wow g3 king g2 i thought that might have
been a mouse slip but
i suppose not i don't know that looks a
little bit suspicious of that
file getting up and now you mentioned
the petrov yesterday on my stream i
was actually checking out the original
book by russian master alexander petrov
after whom the opening is named in the
early 1800s
he authored i think the very first chess
book ever written in the russian
language
and it's available in fully digitized
form online and
it was just fascinating to read how uh
no
even proper chess notation didn't really
exist uh at the time what a legacy that
this guy left on the game now wesley and
dude are playing the opening
uh named after him yeah some people call
it legacy others call it misery because
trying to
beat the petra from the white side it's
been a task
that players have struggled with for a
very long time
interesting because in russian people
don't really say petrov they say russian
game
yes but in other languages you mostly
say petra you don't say russian game but
in
in uh russian you also say spanish game
for rye lopez you never really say rai
lopez just an interesting little tidbit
although i guess in english these days
we just called the spanish right
like i always called the rai i mean i'm
one of the cool guys
i'm also kind of you know one of those
you know
we'll talk back to the chest back in the
chest back to the chest
but we've got a position that's a little
bit symmetrical
well no g pawns here and
donna you made a comment earlier which
is a very smart one
that taking away from the center opened
up the rook on that faith the problem is
come end game time or middle game time
those pawns can be targets and in
particular this part on g6 now but
wesley is using the f file to his
advantage how do you weigh that when
you're assessing this position donya
do you prefer white's open f file
because i certainly prefer the pawn
structure
for white rather than the file for black
now normally i prioritize peace
placement but
the thing is here duda can trade on e8
and go rookie one
so i kind of agree with you and then you
can situate a rook on e3
the problem is you know people talk
about the principle of two weaknesses uh
you know
oftentimes it's not enough to have one
weakness you gotta create another one
but
i think it's also worthwhile to think
about it from the other side principle
of two strengths
it's often not enough to have one main
asset in your position such as an open
file because
the opponent can adjust to that you sort
of need two distinct
areas of the border factors where you
are superior
and here we only see one and duda is
nicely adjusting to it by over
protecting that knight on f3
pawn on f2 is protected so i think he's
got tiny pull
but wesley shouldn't have really any
problems uh holding this particularly
with that nice time advantage he's built
and i was about to say that judo is
probably going to take with the pawn e3
to take advantage of the pawn structure
because
look at this position black has three
pawns to whites two
but because white's pawns are undoubled
and black spawns are
creating a pass pawn is not really
possible unfortunately you have these
double pawns and that's
the downside of the dull pawns plus side
another open file downside
hard to create past pawns in end game so
that is why duda
took towards the center because if you
cut the board at the e file
white has a five on four from a to e
and black has a three on two output in
quotes because they're not creating a
past pawn so what white
wants to do is trade off all the pieces
go to a king and pawn end game
and then play e4 and have a four on
three advantage you essentially have
an extra pawn in king and pawn end game
terms
that's a great explanation um could not
have said it any better myself and and
that's
always something people forget to do i
think is is sort of prognosticate okay
what happens if
this piece is removed from the port what
happens if we have a pawn end game and
wait i'm getting a call oh the robert
has anti-compliments
yeah i wasn't supposed to oh sorry okay
i'm off the commentary but the
committee for not complimenting robert
has just gave me a call but
i'll talk to them later and here we see
wesley getting the knight to f5 so he's
adding some heat to the position
robert and it has to be pointed out that
with these three pieces on the board an
attack is not out of the question
tactics related to white's king are not
out of the question and have to be
considered
yeah the main problem i would say though
after knight to five which is right that
there's maybe even a sacrifice later on
h4 this knight can just hop into e5
where it closes down
the queen from e3 and importantly i'm
just going to show this very quickly
it's uh
just a simple sort of tactical idea is
that if i can say
put my queen to c2 with check or if i
can just
run my queen over c2 you'll take me oh
free queen
then i have knight takes e3 maneuvers so
distracting the white queen
is very much in play because the e3
square
may be too much of a target to keep an
eye on
yeah and and look at wesley now poking
and prodding at
dude as uh center c5 trying to undermine
the knights
let me tell you that this is getting
very concerning with all of this
all of the stuff that duda has to keep
together maybe queen e4
what is wesley threatening exactly i'm
not sure but it just
feels like there's tactics in the air b5
is an idea involving that other pawn
you mentioned the second rank a2
cool it's not easy to keep white's
position together and
that's the good sign of having this
double pawn on g6
is your king can kind of have a shield
if it
gets to the square whereas without this
f2 pawn white's king feels a little bit
more iffy and so
a lot to consider here for wesley he's
also uh next enough was it for
a younger student and duda is down quite
a lot of time for the second game in a
row
but uh maybe he should put the griffin i
don't really care when i'm down on the
clock but this is a very concerning
position
but okay let's see what he does and in
fact d5 has been played and
things start to fall apart here for uh
jan shishtoff
i would be worried about his position
for sure because now c4 is directly
under attack
you take on b5 you have to watch out for
the a2 pawn
how do you even continue here
but this is the kind of yeah d5 that
knight on e5 is what concerned him
he puts a rook on a four he's trying to
sort of you know assume that
defensive stance but bc is possible then
maybe he wants d5
oh i don't know and that actually would
be the ideal
in terms of pawn structure situation if
you could allow you allowed the capture
on c4 played d5
because then black's queen side pawns
will not be connected as we head
closer and closer to an end game and he
does take there so
d5 didn't yeah don't take on d5 because
we take d5
check i i thought maybe black should put
his king on h7
wait nights it's a fork oh just kidding
you're in check
right exactly that's the whole problem
okay so now wesley has to find maybe
queen b6
uh to open up that avenue to b2 but then
duda could take on c4 with a knight to
cover that square
so again this is really heated up and
what's really good for wesley's got the
time
to really think through this critical
moment but i'm not sure he's got a great
solution to this
it's the transition that he's not going
to be very thrilled about because white
towards the end game has now two
unopposed past pawns
the double pawns we've talked about
those enough for now and the isolated
pawns and the queen set are going to be
a bad thing
it's hard to push them when they're not
connected you know i have the feeling
that
judah's position was really falling
apart but it just seems that he was in
this move
rook four he's managed to stabilize it
maybe queen okay queen e8
drops it back did you see me click on c6
just there
uh i did not i was watching through live
chess
yeah i accidentally but touched the
queen and touched the c6 squad oh so you
played queen c6 yeah
yeah wow that's that's awesome yeah and
i i think i'll never forget when rob
the time that robert had played queen c6
like queen 64 though
not only is the queen called the
diagonal uh queen a4 is just on the same
diagonal
yes i like i had i was in the right path
but daniel 82 is hanging
but queenie four queen takes g6 queen e4
king age seven queen takes g6 and knight
e5
wait what if king f6 okay so if queenie
said uh
i think white could have gone queen e6
check instead okay let's uh go to the
analysis board real quick
okay h7 queen takes g6 wait
what oh my god king f6
knight g4 to save the knight and then
you take through anyway it's not
important uh i
i didn't mean to derail us from the game
because i was dude's got sex now
west is gonna do something similar
oh potentially you scared me rookie
played
potentially queen takes c4 ideas in the
air
but it didn't work just yet but now
these pawns starting to fall
but the knight on f5 is undermined it is
and the d-pawn is ready to start
rolling d67 coming to a theater near you
this is a really good one man yeah
thanks anyway so
in a1 queen a1 i see your idea trying to
get to
h1 over here very subtle but then rook
f1 shuts that down
and i thought queen e5 for a second but
white's pieces are all perfectly placed
except for the front of h3 i don't think
you want the king on h3 but
considering where black pieces are the
king is as safe as it will get
yeah maybe you want to go some crazy now
that doesn't work
i'm thinking about all sorts of crazy
ideas that's one hallmark of 2700 plus
chess
uh which which might be a sort of a
banal observation but
their pieces are always so good i mean
even black's pieces are good
uh the sort of superiority is marginal
but it's just enough to
send black into a tailspin and now
wesley dipping below 30 seconds
i don't see a move i don't see a single
resource as of yet
it's amazing that undermining the knight
and f5 just does so much damage the
knight of c4 is
great here and well protected the knight
and f5 should be well protected by a
pawn but that pawn's being removed in 18
seconds counting down here
for wesley and jkd only has 7.6 himself
but unless he can't find a move he can't
find a move and
who can blame him i mean neither can we
five sec okay queen anyone played rook
f1 queen f6 maybe
ah this way no but d6 and then he said
check okay so he brings some of his
pieces back duda has to be careful
here comes rook f7 and steve queen d5 on
top of that oh
yeah 35 queen at queen f7 also oh my
goodness that's brutal
and he does it ready queen of fate made
it over
we'll bring up the analysis board i just
want to show how the concluding touch
could have been really nice if queen
takes f7 you can take either way
rook f8 stops the pawn but then i go d7
you move your knight and i go
d8 equals queen i give up my one pawn
and promote the second
and that way
a rook here so that would be game over
what a display
surgical precision by duda who again it
felt like wesley had that initiative
going
but uh it was the structural
deficiencies in his position
uh in the end that reigns supreme when
studio was able to stabilize
the situation and he delivers the first
blow what a game
and while we talked about pawn structure
in the last game we might as well
continue the trend
that pawn on d4 is an isolated pawn now
for now that's fine
white is going to castle and when you
have an isolated pawn the adjacent files
are open you want to put a work on c1 a
rook on e1
great and operate using that pawn to
your advantage
however as we get later and later into
the game and that isolated pawn remains
then i can try to attack it because a
pawn's best friend
is another pawn look at this pawn on e6
extremely well defended thanks to a pawn
f7 you're not attacking that
ever the pawn d4 has to be protected by
pieces
which means that more of white's
attention will be uh forced
on that square and that should allow
black to then start putting pressure
and taking advantage of that so danya
it's still very early
you know these iqp i say the queen pone
positions very well
how do you see this game going and which
side would you rather have here
well i like the two bishops uh and uh
in the iqp we have to watch for two
things if we're looking at white's
position
his potential to break through in the
center with d5 which absolves him of the
weakness
and i'm not saying by the way he's going
to do that right now doesn't work
because of 95 but just
what to watch for uh if you can get d5
in and
he can do so successfully he'll have all
of the advantages of his position
and he rids himself of the isolated pawn
that's number one
number two is does white have attacking
chances on the king side
that's what wesley is orienting himself
toward he's shifting his bishop to d3
that queen can travel to h3 and uh
it's impossible to give made in one fell
swoop you often want to provoke a
weakness such as g6 or h6
that in turn creates an anchor or a
weakness on f6
or a pawn that you can sacrifice your
bishop on uh but
you have to do all of this while
negotiating and buying yourself time
in regards to that isolated pawn which
judah will pile up on while making other
improvements in his position i like
white's position
rook a d1 maybe but wesley's also got to
be very very careful yeah
yeah rook 81 gives you the idea of later
playing d5 it also just defends the pawn
and the bishop can slide back to b1 for
good measure so what i'll say dania
is and how we were kind of talking about
it is that
for white you want to build up attacking
chances
because your pawn structure is worse so
you know that
if you don't get that attack and let's
say the queens come off the board
then black is much happier right because
you have this i said pawn so what
black ideally does is say hey it's a
it's a fair trade queen versus queen
let's just get these two off the board
right now
and then i'm going to blockade and then
attack your pawn so a very common idea
for black
is to bring a knight to d5 and say your
pawn's not moving
and meanwhile well now you're clearly
threatening things with the bishop on
the
diagonal but you were trying to start
trading some pieces and then later in
the game go after that
yeah and as you were explaining i was
looking at the shelf behind me i used to
well i think i still have it but i can't
find it a book by
a grandmaster alexander baburin who uh
i think lives in ireland now originally
of course russian and he wrote
an entire book on pawn structures but
most of it was focused on the iqp
and i remember really liking that book
uh and then
i remember a facebook post i think this
was a year or so ago
and i think this just happens on amazon
when a book is out of print
uh but somebody posted a baburn's book i
think it's called winning pawn
structures
was listed at 900 a pop or something
like that
man if you want to understand the iqp
you gotta you gotta shell out you gotta
buy iqp insurance or something
to cover part of that well played there
and yeah the
iqp it's and it can be an expensive pawn
so
you know that makes sense the book would
also be pricey and
knight takes d4 would also be pricey let
me tell you oh let's see
i'll show that tactic very quickly here
the point is that there's a rook
there will be a queen the rook wins that
battle and
you are able to take on each of them
with check to boot
opening up an attack on the queen that
just wins the game uh by winning black's
queen directly
so that's not something you can capture
yet i could see a rook d7 move in the
future that
puts more pressure on d4 g5 idea
mission pc5 is gonna be very nasty
though you're absolutely right
all right bishop g5 threatening the h7
pawn and h6
i know you've done it you're gonna
sacrifice or try to on that square but
whenever there's an h6 and a sacrifice
there you have to
be sure that it amounts to something now
often in these positions
white can store a draw by uh
okay let's just show this let's put the
analysis board and show these kind of
ideas
where let's say uh in the movie go rook
d7 bishop g5 just to
go through with this that if we get a
position like this right
we have a check back and forth exactly
so that's important because otherwise
the move like rook takes d4 would be a
big problem
for white in many regards but you can at
the very least
go back and forth and make a draw so you
say then it's
worth diving even more deeply into this
and now that you see the draw
you put that in your back pocket and say
where is more the eval bars is plus one
there must be something in white's favor
it's your lucky coin
not in your pocket anywhere anywhere but
your pocket
do you know what do you know what movie
that's from all right javier you know
calm yourselves
pretty good it's your old
coin what do you
make of this d5 move that's a actually a
very thematic
sacrifice now this looks like madness
he's putting his pawn
where it can be taken by 884 pieces but
the reality is
knight on f6 cannot move if he takes
with a pawn
then yes wesley has sacked upon but he
can position that bishop on e3 to d4
centralizing it and targeting the knight
on f6 he's got tremendous compensation
both positionally and tactically so due
to trying to takes for the knight
uh and after knight takes he'll probably
take with a bishop
again taking the queen results in a
discovery
uh but maybe wesley still goes bishop d4
i don't think that he's got
uh you know massive compensation but
this just seems a lot more pleasant
bishop g5 by the way is still possible
and
there's a new wrinkle to this now that
the position has opened up a little bit
so
this is scary for black i really i'm
starting to like black's position i'm
not
quite believing in the attack the way
that you seem to be
and that could just be me having some
oversight saying ah
you know whatever i you know i like
sacrificing people's pieces so
uh something about this doesn't quite
feel like the attack is as strong as it
wants to be but i also
completely understand what you're saying
either bishop d4 bishop g5
and pile up on h7 or if you
play h6 go for the sacrifice so that's
really what this all comes down to and
dude it might take with the pawn
on d5 and no okay never mind i just
can't get over the
i think some people thought i lost my
mind and didn't realize it was a
reference
and here we're going to see a reference
to bishop takes h6 there we have it
and again he does have that draw in his
pocket i think i don't think duda can do
anything about it maybe rookie 8
actually rookie 8 can be a very annoying
resource
oh but he goes and said for queen e7 and
the bar just
freaked out so i don't like that i think
rookie a might have been actually
a very serious resource so you're trying
to make space for the king and
eventually to run away yeah that's
exactly what i'm doing that move wasn't
liked either so
what do you think what's going on here
why did it go plus two points and let's
bring up the analysis board so we can
try to figure this out
it went plus two about to then back to
equal after the very
natural rookie one move which is trying
to get rookie through rook g3
what does black do with rookie five
bishop b4
i wonder you know donya i get the
feeling that i know what's happening
here
so let's see if rook's here there could
be a problem
down the d file in some of these
variations so i believe
the superior option was rook d-e-1
the most counter-intuitive move ever
because you want to bring another
attacker
there's no bishop before in the end wow
that's that is actually awesome
detective work robert well i see i see
the eval right and that's what's leading
me to the conclusion is that you're
saying bishop e4
there's a problem with the rook hanging
on d1 so dania
how do we make these work in our own
games rather than just using an eva bar
to get the answer
it's difficult and i mean this everybody
can appreciate the subtlety of this the
finesse required to
perceive this in advance that's part of
the reason chess is such a magical game
the game goes down to these tiny moments
and at the end of the day it's all about
undefended
pieces lpdo loose pieces drop off one of
my favorite
shorthands uh that is a very helpful
thing to remind yourself of
every single time you have a piece
undefended by any other pieces
particularly one that's on the first
rank that is a liability
and uh you know it's not that you want
to eliminate those pieces
actively but when you have one of those
pieces that opens up the potential for
for tactics and uh this is hard to see
because it's so natural right
who would play rook d one and leave the
other rook on f1 to do absolutely
nothing
uh and yet everything comes down to
concrete properties of the position when
you are attacking
the rules of engagement are different
than when you're just trying to improve
all of your pieces
and what a lovely move rook c5 just
trying to get rid of this attacker
which is of course going to g5 at some
moment so rook c5 says you go to g5
though
i'll take you and queen g5 is that a
drawer's black i always control
i can drop my bishop to g6 so i need to
think about the right
configuration right because you still
can't take me on g6 with your bishop
with a rook hang with check but
i'm not positive i'm just not throwing
in ideas and for everybody who's
watching
that rook de1 move i would not find that
in a blitz game myself i just saw the
eval bar
rook fe1 looks logical oh wait now i'm
looking at rook d8 is the response
here is where things can improve and i
should again look at that rook on d1 it
is really burning wesley right now i
think he recognizes it
he i think he's losing this and his
clock is burning too ten seconds
under things for both players he's got
to trade pieces and okay but now rook
takes king takes g8
okay it's not over yet he's got two
let's not forget he's got oh he's got
only one pawn for the piece he got it
one second one second oh my gosh he
barely got that move off
barely rook d5 is possible here what am
i doing he's going to move
he's got some time and westy shakes his
head he just but
even in the end i mean he could have
tried but uh at that point duda had
consolidated
two points ahead look at this
performance in the early going by
jkd incredible defense a chance missed
by wesley but as you pointed out robert
that is
so hard to see now this is just
something that
when you have the eval bar on you see
that rook f21 is
zeros and but it was almost plus two
hey now you have to think outside the
box a little bit i'm going to store that
one
i'm gonna write that down later to uh
use in
future lessons because rook d e one what
a clever way to go for
and dania this opening that we have now
in game
four wesley shows pawns well advanced
in front of his castle's king that can
backfire but it also can use to restrict
the pieces for instance
we see a bishop on g3 we know that's not
the best bishop because all of these
pawns
on the dark squares make it uh pretty
useless on the diagonal but
how do you feel about these positions i
think that the light squares in
particular f5 in the future could be a
problem but
i now pass it over to you because you're
gonna be able to explain this better
well i play this with black uh and and
the italian is the kind of opening of
course it was
all the rage in you know the 1700s uh my
voyage
gioquino graco and all those early
masters and then there was a period when
people sort of
at the highest level switched to the ray
lopez and now it's all the rage again
because it's it's a very rich opening
it's a very hard to understand opening
there's a lot of subtle ideas now
of course uh square on f5 robert is very
weak white can strike in the center with
d4 and black's position can collapse
very quickly on the other hand
black has very specific ideas in
relation to
it's sort of blitz in in in football
right you're rushing the quarterback
if he gets the pass off okay he's
probably going to find a receiver
downfield but he might get sacked
and the equivalent of that is h5 h4
ideas f5 ideas
black is going to try to mount that
blitz before white gets his knight to e3
and plays d4 is he going to manage to do
that that's why he played knight g8 he's
trying to
open up the passage for that f1 here we
see it will do to be able to respond to
this precisely
right and if he gets d foreign not only
can he avoid a concussion but he can
cause some harm to his opponent so uh
this is a position where
black is in some danger of having pushed
too far
overextended on the king side which is
the nature
of the way you play this opening for
from wesley's perspective and for jkd
another decision do i take with the rook
or do i take with the pawn if he takes
with the pawn he has to think about e4
as a possibility at some point for black
saying your pawn e3 will be a weakness
rather than a strength and if he takes
to the rook
he has to look at this rook on f8 as is
that a strong rook
or what is it just looking good in a
semi-open file so now the file is fully
open
i was just checking to see the last year
in which the new york giants won a game
uh but my research failed me mm-hmm
but i mean the giants have won three
games this year and
just so you know i grew up as a jets fan
and
just have one zero games so
man i'm well i grew up as a 49ers fan so
i
share in the plights but in any case are
we supposed to be compensating chess or
is this
you're the one who made the unnecessary
football results usually it's sports
that makes a
oh it's a stalemate out there and i'm
always like you know stalemate the game
is over right so it's
not a stalemate right like i just want
all announcers in sports if somebody
sends us them just so they know
when they call the middle of a game a
stalemate because
neither side is making progress that's
not a stalemate
just the game continues the rant uh
completely on the same page to continue
right
when somebody let's tell al michaels and
all the john madden
oh bill belichick and jim harbaugh are
engaged in a chess match here it's gonna
be a real chess match
they're gonna try to check me that
doesn't tell anything about anything
that's happening this
is the most generically used term uh
in in sports coverage ever but well how
would you feel
if they were like they're engaged in zuk
suang right now you'd be like wait what
what's going on here like imagine they
use that correctly
you know i do appreciate it when chess
is used but
uh it's interesting that you know these
terms stalemate and checkmate have made
it out into sort of the common sports
comparison vocabulary i don't know it's
just interesting but
wesley's the one trying to deliver
trackmate here i don't think he's going
to succeed
um yeah i know i don't think so either
but the 994 does look very good
the bishop one h2 still does not look
particularly promising
but what jkd is holding on hope for is
d4
you mentioned this idea it is thematic
in the white side of the italian game
can i get d4 in and break open the
position but west is just creating many
problems
along this f file where he has just
better control
yeah and here comes the doubling on the
f phone and what has he managed to do
here what he's managed to do
has been to sort of close off the center
minimize
the impact of white's pluses and
maximize the impact of his own pluses in
particular that knight on f4 incredibly
strong
it can be replaced by a rook should it
be captured uh he's definitely better
here this is a big chance for him bishop
h5
what duda can try to do here is move the
knight away from f3 and basically say
okay
we're at a stalemate come at me
bro because i've got that bishop on h2
assuming that defensive role
putting the brakes on any potential g4
mode because that weakens and softens up
that f4 knight which can be captured
so that was that was very well played
done yeah
that was extremely well done um you're
right though that if you can move the
knight let's say knight g1 play g3
even though it makes your bishop look
not very good on h2 for the time being
if you could trade off
most of the heavy pieces you're not
getting yourself in any trouble
and for wesley how does he actually
increase the pressure here he
says my knight and c6 let's just go back
a half step knight c6
dominated by a pawn three squares away
let me reroute that piece
and knight to g1 so he's trying to get
g3 in
yeah sorry and i just found out klay
thompson had achilles
okay i'm kind of devastated but anyways
uh that was
my turn yesterday i'm sorry i did not
hear that i this is just the first time
hearing about it
g3 would be a big blunder though knight
takes d3 is a problem now
yeah so bishop c2 okay back to the game
what dude is trying to do is shore up
all of his
potential weaknesses that bishop on c2
we say the bad bishops
defend ooh and g3 that's a very
committal decision
look at that bishop on h2 uh there have
been better bishops in the history of
bishopdom
but the plus side of this is bad bishops
defend
good pawns said romanian grandmaster
mihai shuba
great chess author by the way and that
pawn on g3 is fulfilling a crucial role
it's covering the f4 square
look at the knight on h5 it isn't too
happy either so wesley trying to find
alternate ways into white's position
sacking the pawn to soften up that e4
pawn
yeah i think that black's vision looks
excellent because while white is
holding off black's pieces that's the
best way to describe it
why is not attacking white is not
threatening anything
there's nothing of consequence that
black needs to be on the lookout for in
fact
everything that's weak in the position
is what white has to defend rather than
the other way around and look at this
taking on the f file
saying i can control the f5 if i want
the queen had to stay put defending the
e4 pawn and hey knight f6 wins
f6 yep knight f6 is going to be very
nasty very hard to deal with wesley
trying to see
queen f7 check if he can do that in a
better way he can
he's going to take on c4 and he's gonna
attack e4 this is
excellent work here in this middle game
by wesley patiently poking and prodding
and then
seizing the opportunity will do to be
able to coordinate his defensive forces
this is looking pretty grim but i
wouldn't rule it out and i take c4 check
nice he's going to lose i mean bishop
before queen e4 and
some chances there for white but should
be losing i think
yeah the bishop is so weak on h2 and if
you play g4 i don't even have to go
knight f4
but i can think about it so this bishop
a bishop three squares away from knight
certainly dominates it
even more so than a pawn does the knight
h5 clearly better than this bishop on h2
and black is up upon better pieces
more material and a minute extra on the
clock looks good for wesley's chances
yeah and knight f6 here is possible
trying to reroute the knight to g4 the
newly created weakness
uh in general in the end game it's a
good idea to fully understand burying
the bishop on
on h2 and the pawn on g3 is now a
permanent weakness
it's a good idea whenever a pawn is
pushed to understand which weak squares
have been created that tells you a lot
about how you should position your
pieces here for example
black now has the f3 square he can
situate a bishop there potentially
uh he can also bring i mean there's just
so many attempts or b5
i just want to be careful when you push
puns not to trade too many of them so
we'll see how he plays this he is i
mentioned robert yeah
i'm looking at the king you mentioned
the f3 square i was thinking the king
could also try to get
into f3 oh absolutely there's room there
for two
well no there's room there for one but
the knight on e4
pressuring g3 now i like the point you
were making about not trading
too many pawns or at least being aware
of which pawns you should trade
because now oh yeah wins upon no not
trading points but then the ship c7 at
the end
good call hmm how about so
tricky i also want to play d5 and then
bishop b5 check but the problem is
you know we can analyze it later but
nice if if i take on um
f1 which is one the king would have
taken on e4 so knight f6 in the end of
that line
instead of bishop takes uh f1 oh
so maybe we can show that later yeah
maybe d5 was good we're doing that whole
gm thing where we're just analyzing
to our own benefit and everybody has
today what are these fools
discussing right now uh this pawn on g3
remains weak
but the knight and f1 stabilizing that
for the time being the bishop on b6
it was such a bad bishop before now it's
doing quite a good job on b6
stopping the b7 pawn from moving and
covering the length and diagonal
yeah and wesley's so good in these
positions his technical skill is
basically unparalleled and here comes
the sun here comes d5 now bishop b5
trying to of course dislodging the
knight from f1 but 93 check and then the
bishop assumes the defensive role from
e1
due to doing a great job apportioning
his limited resources
the problem is robert you called it i
think the king is coming in through e4
to f3
and that is going to be a doomsday
scenario for white is that king is going
to wreak absolute havoc on the defensive
forces
the yeah big issue is the g3 pawn is a
weakness that can't be moved and you
can't don't take on e3
i would go about and do that actually it
might not be so bad not king e3 and e4
usually you're too quick i think it's
winning but i wouldn't risk it and
he doesn't yeah that's definitely the
safer play here
and the knight can come to f oh but
there's 96 check what what
i'm trying to highlight is you don't
really want to trade knights because
a single extra pawn in an opposite color
bishop and ending gives the side with
the material deficit good chances to
hold
so knight f5 along 96 would not be good
instead of king of three giving the e5
to win g3 and that gives you a nice pass
pawn
and bishop d6 do the last ditch attempt
but
that's pretty effective robert king
takes g3 you don't want to do
because it would have lost the knight
instead setting his pawn in motion but
now the bishop from d6 guards g3 but he
has a bigger problem to worry about
that's the e pawn
and knight f5 in the picture two seconds
on the clock he's not maybe not gonna
get that out yeah
it's over and a great game a great
recovery by wesley
taking a bite out of that early lead
winning with the black faces in an
italian
that was a great game technically very
precise and you mentioned it he's very
hard to tilt
very hard yeah right after losing uh two
of the first three games
going down by a two and a half half
score you would think hey does he feel
like he
has to win does he have to do something
really impressive
he did push his pawns from his king but
that was part of a standard
opening set up and then he went forward
from there and look at this game right
now we're in a territory where
white has trade off the queens even
material
but pawn structure is not symmetrical
and white is
first to the threat right bishop to b6
hits the rope
this rook on d1 is attacking a bishop
this rook is defending said bishop
and i'm not saying that black is in huge
danger but you have to know what you're
doing
and there is an opportunity after rook
d7 to play move like knight c5 and
potentially get the
bishop pair as we head in more towards
the ending or
play move like c4 to kick the bishop
it's a lot to work out here
if you are jk and this move rook g1
on the sixth move of the night or is a
move that uh
that basically has made a resurgence
recently it was really popularized by
ivan chuck my research tells me was
first played
in the year 1990 by the yugoslavian
international master goron todorovic
uh and it was played several times in
the early 90s
popularized in the late 90s but it's
sort of been
re-retooled in in recent years after
gary kasparov
night off specialist made a a dent in it
so interesting to
observe the sort of uh opening fashions
here and
like you said robert i think white's
developed some very unpleasant pressure
here with bishop h3 ideas bishop c5
dude has got to keep his position
together he does indeed and
not easy for him clearly spending clock
but that has been
a theme a trend i should say of the
longest time patrol
duda is every single game down a minute
on the clock at least
and right now no exception to that he's
down a full minute he still has plenty
of time right
three minutes and 49 seconds for blitz
game pieces have been traded off
but wesley moving instantly so dania
knight c5 played here
what to respond with i don't want to
take you yeah
maybe you have to though takes in rook
to i mean at the very least you get rid
of the immediate
initiative but you do acquiesce to the
fact that white has the two bishops
uh what else is there i mean if you move
the bishop from e6 to let's say f5 then
well that
paves the road for the f1 bishop to jump
out onto
c4 so he does take yeah and i like that
decision
and i also like the follow-up king c7
because what was such a thorn in black
side was this bishop on b6
well no b6 square for you in fact black
if he zoo chooses can eventually play b6
as you mentioned rook to d8 is possible
there's also i was going to say
h6 why does my rook need to go to a
different file
instead of going to the open file
directly let me create an open file for
my rook yeah then try to make use of it
and viking try to close that down with a
move g6 that
of course creates its own liabilities uh
because
such a change in pawn structure is a
very responsible decision right black
and play
five or something but i'm leaning toward
g6 here i feel like allowing the opening
of the h file robert is
something just feels a little bit off
about that i mean g takes h6 is probably
a draw but
i think wesley's shooting for more here
he's definitely contemplating g6 will he
play it
i feel like he won't and what
let's just strike that on the record i
just wanted to prove that you would be
right so
if i said something it's the opposite's
going to happen but the reason why i
didn't like g6
and not h5 to follow is these pawns
are closer to where black's pieces are
going to go and could fall
in the end game the reason i like them
is if you can imagine that the rooks get
traded this bishop obviously would come
to f8 and then try to get to the g7 pond
there could be sacrifices
that allow this g-pawn to spring free
very long story but something to keep in
the back of your mind
i am much more concerned about the h5
pawn than i am
about any of black's pawns that no i
think you you make a very fair point
uh because for the time being the rook
on d8 is very
stably holding that that a fate square
is what you really need to watch for if
a bishop lands there as you said
it's not going to be good the other
thing to watch for if the bishop from e3
eventually sacrifices on h6 with that
bishop being on e6 covering the
promotion square it's going to be very
hard to make that work
but still something to watch for and uh
wesley deciding to keep that line of
uh negotiation of the f8 square open
maybe bring the bishop back to c5
but i like judah's activity here and i
agree with you robert i i have to say
even though i
predicted the move i i'm beginning to
lose
uh quite a bit of faith in in white's
position that rook on g1 really tied to
its place
because bishop g4 should be such a
disaster
that's certainly true and i'll add that
the pawn on g6 may look good but the
pawn h5 does not so it's very weird
and typically we say that a
pawns you know a pawn chain is only as
good as its base
the h5 pawn it is a bit difficult to get
to it's on a rook file that means it
will take
quite a bit of energy to go after it but
it's not that easy to defend either and
rook g3 played causing duda to sit and
think
is there some kind of rook to the queen
side coming is there
a c3 or c4 push that will allow you to
take advantage of your queenside pawn
majority
i just like the placement of black's
pieces better look the knight and d4
bishop on e6 rook and d8
harmonious piece placement for duda
yeah i was just finalizing a pun so
hence my delayed response but
i'll share that maybe after the game
because i know it's going to make you
cringe
but now the rook does he takes the
plunge he says all right
i'm going to go for activity come hell
or high water by hook or by crook i'm
going to create some chances against
the black king and i actually really
really like that particularly in the
context of the time situation he's got
a minute and a half extra and maybe
something like a4
to add heat to the position he doesn't
have a lot of time to spare robert
because bishop g4
let's not forget uh is a very big threat
he's got one or two tempe at the maximum
yeah because once h5 falls down and goes
g6 but don't using b2
yes kv2 is certainly an idea and i was
going to say that your a4
idea may be giving up the kingside pawns
to win the queenside pawns then we have
a race
and the bishops are very good in pawn
races because they can
both defend the kingside and also attack
the side the bishop for example
on the d5 square would be able to
threaten the corner
and defend the other ones so that's just
why when their pieces go on both sides
of the board
uh if paul's bus says what i should say
having bishops is tends to be a good
thing
instead prophylaxis by wesley playing f3
accepting new weaknesses but
stopping of course the bishop from
coming to g4 and duda says
i won't be denied he's getting his
knights out for i
don't something with that move f3 seems
a little off now wesley
seems passive again although he does he
has shut off the immediate line of
attack to the h5 pawn
yeah and i was thinking rook c8 but i'm
not sure i want to go
into the rookless ending here uh trading
off allows the bishops to shine
as king to b7 the rook c6 was the idea
and here's your a4 dominion it's
starting to look
more promising for white you're actually
creating some legitimate threats
and rook d5 well that pawn is fulfilling
a
very important role of guarding the c4
square which could be used as a base for
the bishop on f1
but the bishop on f1 could also move
potentially to g2
duda wants to shut that down with knight
f4 in a timely manner
yeah actually now knight f4 is even
stronger and that's why the rook on d5
is nice because if
you take me on f4 i take with the e pawn
i'm opening up the fifth rank
and the h5 pawn and he's trying to
exploit that diagonal f4
e takes f4 would be a very bad blunder
due to bishop g2
what is due to dude is he closed it down
he does with the bishop but f5
that was clever though putting the
bishop on e4 and f5 just puts another
pawn on a light square which i likely
can go after
later in the game so or even immediately
yeah there it is
no no it's an important decision here
for uh for wesley because if you take on
e5 the rook takes and well thank you
for giving me a direct attack on your h5
pawn right i was thinking some bishop g2
e4
rook d3 ideas i mean there are some
ideas down the long diagonal actually
rook d3
here is not out of the question oh it is
maybe yeah okay that's too much
i i love it i'm going to show it let's
bring up the analysis
no no no i love it bishop d3 bishop g2
e4 daniel's idea was if c takes now this
pawn is pinned and if you take with the
rook
thank you for your rook with the check
but of course
black does not have to take on d3 black
and move the rook away for example rook
takes h5
and then b up in exchange and move on
from there so
nice idea though the tactics were almost
working
and instead we saw the trade and we're
seeing a repetition
two times who is the one declining the
repetition
or thinking about declining and i'm not
actually sure i think it's
wesley wesley bishop g2 would lead to a
draw
i think he should yeah i think he should
too
he doesn't have any other chances he
might lose that pawn otherwise
right and this rook on e5 now is superb
and yeah he allows the wait it's not
draw it
it is the draw okay that's a good
decision and we talked about this you
know
wesley realizes he's the only down a
point
uh you don't want to do anything crazy
and just
give up you know another point uh
because there's so much time left in the
match there's just no need for that
and wesley did just win that game with
the black pieces he goes right back to
this line
with the early g5 it looks risky
but wesley proved hey my king does not
actually get in as much trouble as
it could if i'm not careful so he were
kg7 knight g8 last time
this is a great time to share my pun
because they are repeating
uh the line from the previous game we've
already discussed it i'm all here what
did the
swedish grand master say when he came up
with a good move
i have an ikea
oh my gosh there was a reason i thought
of this but
uh the reason is way too elaborate to
talk about
talk about the position i'm in all right
all right all right i'll talk about the
position now uh
so what's going on okay that was
actually pretty okay i can guarantee
a lot of people are laughing we've got
over 10 000 well over 10 000 people and
by the way a huge shout out to everybody
joining us here for this awesome match
but i can guarantee you a good
amount of those people are laughing
right now anyway they're laughing
at you not with you my friend but that's
they're still laughing i
mean bottom line is i made people laugh
whether it's at me or
with me that's less important you made
me cringe
um can you talk about the chess
yes so we have a slightly different
structure and here we have the position
heating up d5 by duda basically what
why did he do that he did not want to
allow wesley to drive that wedge into
the position
by playing d5 himself now there's a
problem wesley takes on f3
dude is going to take on c6 and who does
this favor how do we think about this
well
remember dude is the one with the two
bishops and wesley is the one with the
weak king
so queen takes f3 he dude has got the e
file the c6 pawn is weak
unless wesley comes up with some magical
way to coordinate his pieces and fast
he's gonna be in trouble here maybe
queen d7 coordinate the rooks try to put
a rook on e8
queen d7 by the way threatens bishop g4
which would trap the queen
um but still bishop a4 now
i think is very unpleasant oh nice
so he plays this first to get rookie
seven check bishop g4
traps the queen but rookie 7 is check
winning black's queens it plays rookie
now bishop a4 your idea makes sense
is there something knight d5 wait uh
okay can i trade take on d5 no it
doesn't work so i'll just bring up the
analysis board
so that we're not doing that thing where
we're just talking in our heads bishop
a4
puts pressure on c6 knight d5 says no
can do i'm blocking your queen and i was
wondering if i could sack my queen
to get your queen back but unfortunately
at the rookie seven check i'm just
trading everything off i have to take
first
and then rook f7 saves the day so it's
uh protecting the seventh rank opposite
colored bishops
should just be in equal game so
we didn't get that with queen d1 and the
action continues
opposite colored bishops and the
opposite excuse me
two bishops for white knight and bishop
for black
pawns on both sides of the board so in
theory donya
at the very least that should favor dude
his chances
yeah uh definitely he is the one pushing
for the advantage but uh it should also
be pointed out that wesley is he's
pretty active
uh and due to going after the queen
trade which again
as you pointed out makes perfect sense
that pawn structure on on
the queen side is incredibly concerning
in the long run for wesley
i don't think it's uh indefensible i
think even if he trades queens it should
be a draw with best play
but that's a pretty big asterisk because
it's you know it's hard to find
all those subtleties and in energy maybe
you take and you go bishop to d3 nope he
keeps the queens on the board
but now h4 ideas come into mind and uh
kingside attack is also not out of the
question
right and that's an added benefit of
keeping the queens on is you can attack
an exposed king
but i understand wesley's reluctance
to trade the queens off when you think
about things in how we're taught right
bishop pair better than knight and
bishop when they're
pawns on both sides of the board double
pawns not very promising
so the elements of the nuances of the
position
certainly favor white from a high level
thought process
so why should i trade queens and then
remove any chance i may have
of sort of fending off some of the
bigger threats but i still like
jkd's position that's for sure and
bishop b1 very interesting he's going
after that a pawn he was he wanted to
play c4 and maybe he still does
and then redeploy that bishop to c3 that
is
you know that's park place that's the
central park
apartments oh wait i referenced new york
west coast festival's just for the
record
but uh when's once that bishop gets
there it's going to exert tremendous
pressure on the knight and here we see
it that pawn on a4 is also
a very very big weakness so a double
whammy here for wesley
who is going to have to find some way to
keep his position together
and we have a rare occurrence wesley is
down on the clock against jkd
and a big problem in addition to the a4
pawn being a weakness
how about this a2 pawn being an outside
pass pawn what am i thinking
eventually play a3 to make sure i keep
that pawn cemented in place
then play b3 spring free the outside
pass pawn now d5 says
hey i'm going to try to get some play
for myself because my position
is not looking good if that bishop got
to c3 but now what have you done
isolated doubled pawns isolated a pawn
queen in the center not a fan
uh pawn structure is not not fun now you
don't want to
rush with bishop takes a4 that would
allow a queen trade at the end of the
line
i think judah needs to find some way to
tighten the screw oh he does play a
should pay for but i don't know about
that did he calculate queen d4 check
queen d4 i guess he said the outside
pass pawn should be good
and donna i'm with you like trading
queens seems to give
black decent chances to hold the game
but what he's probably
thinking about and he's going through
the motions quite quickly here
is i have an a pawn and i also have an
extra pawn on the king side we have this
three on two
so white is up a pawn we have the
opposite color bishop dynamic but i am
going to keep your bishop
keeping after the a pawn and your king
staying on the king side after one of
these three pawns
and that makes black slide very
difficult as white's king will then go
try to run over into the queen side so
i'm ultimately with you that i think
this
clearly increases black's chances to
hold
but at the same time i believe that
white has really significant winning
chances
without a doubt and uh it's it's good
that you pointed that out because a lot
of people look at this and
they wave their hand and ah opposite
colored bishops draw
uh but and oftentimes that is indeed the
case but i think in recent years
uh with these modern computers with the
rise of magnus
we've begun to realize that the drawing
margins if you will in many positions
are a lot
narrower than we initially thought and
you pointed out the two pass bonds as
they say in russian trousers
you have that apon number one and you
basically have a past f pawn at any
moment on demand you can play g3 and f4
and create a second passer
and the ultimate concept here is to
overextend
black's defensive resources black is
gonna have to assign the bishop the apon
and the king the f1
but that's a very uh risky situation
white could employ his king as well
not gonna be easy to win bishop d3 is
coming here i think
but don't you like danya that the bishop
cut off the pawns from each other
because
black would have loved to establish
connected pawns and the bishop won't be
forced and not so fast that's a great
idea
and and you've got to prevent that but
black does have the idea of inching his
king toward d5
another thing to factor into the
calculus here white could go even g4 at
some point
in order to fix the h and g pawns on
dark squares and then try to pick them
off with bishop f8
we'll see what he chooses maybe king f2
for now uh just to see where what black
does
oh there we go nice so dania i think
that
he's making uh both these
uh come true right the pawns on the
queen side
are sorry in the center of the board are
split you can't get c5 and to protect so
this pawn will either have to go to d3
in which case you free up the
other pieces and can i so
it takes king g7 is to say da wants to
go to h6 very good
there's a problem with this very
concrete problem gh5
oh bishop c5 our same idea bishop c5
bishop
three are basically catch and he plays
bishop city
and go look at look at us and the
problem is that king h6
h4 cool idea h4 and then you take the
pun and that is
not just trousers that's
[Laughter]
winning strategy very simple the bishop
holds together look at the bishop
multitasking
that's the one thing knights can't do
the bishop multitasking defending g5
protecting d2
the king saunters its way to the queen
side and says
bishop on a6 enjoy your stay at uh
the marriott uh a6 city because your
residence is about to end
once the bishop once the king lands on
b6 just don't take this pawn
because the king for white is cut off so
if this bishop were to move
d2 happens and you can't stop it so
that's the one he's going to do that
for sure absolutely that's it that's a
little that's a tricky move though these
players they find tricks
until the last drop of blood has spilled
robert they have no resources and yet
they're finding ways to
to uh you know to go for tricks but
duda of course a professional and what
presence of mind by
a jkd to to recognize intuitively that
the send game is
is winning and now that i saw this
played out i think it it was winning
i've seen enough opposite color bishop
type positions in the pro
and it's a win for jkd he goes up two
games once more but enough opposite
color bishop
type of positions in the pro-chess
league and various commenting events
to be on the lookout for hey wait a
second there typically are ideas that
provide winning chances and
dania i grew up probably similar to you
like we learned that opposite-colored
bishops
shh it should be a draw like most the
time they're draw but i've
fought really hard against that initial
thought to say
no let's look for the winning chances
and there goes duda
right and um again the contributions of
magnus here have to be indicated
uh he's sort of said stuff like i don't
believe in fortresses
uh and and we take that with with a
grain of salt but there's definitely a
grain of truth to that
uh in the sense that you know the
resources are so abundant
and we realize that now in in positions
where previously we would have
dismissed them i think as as drawn or as
devoid of
of resources and we see another night
off this one a little bit more peaceful
and as we've already pointed out this
time duda deploys his knight to the
traditional d7 square whereas in game
one
uh he put it on c6 right he played a
much more active plan knight c6 knight
a5
here now it's wesley's pawn on a5 bishop
on e3
trying to take over the b6 square that's
why the knight on d7 is so important
and it also is important because if this
knight we're on c6 i'll just
show you this very quickly let's say
knight d5 knight takes d5 pawn takes d5
for instance
there's no knight on c6 getting under
attacking with a fork so the 97 is much
better placed
right and h6 again we see a little bit
of posturing here both sides improving
their position
uh the idea of h6 obviously uh remove
back rank problems but also create the
g5 square
that might seem insignificant but there
are some positions when a bishop lands
on g5
and so wesley drops his bishop back to
f2 interesting interesting move
and that donna maybe i'm getting
aggressive all of a sudden because i'm
looking at the score
seeing wesley's play are there ideas in
the future for g4
or is that just asking for way too much
um
no i think there are and actually that's
that's one thing you can do is is lolly
your opponent to sleep but
knight h5 preempting that going for the
f4 square so he's fulfilling the same
idea as in the beginning
knight a5 knight c4 but on the other
side of the board this time not h5
knight f4
wesley's saying no you're not you're not
going nowhere
right and bishop g5 could have been an
option but if not for the d6 pawn right
i was using
the bishop move to try to show everybody
that this
d6 pawn is a huge problem for black but
i guess
wesley figured the c2 pawn is a problem
for him and he wants to free up his
knight but yep
i don't like the way this is going for
wesley now d5 is
on the radar i have three defenders of
that square
you uh don't have enough attackers and
why is this
what rooksy one rook right back to d1 i
guess we have to
give him a shout out for when you
recognize your mistake and there are no
huge consequences just say don't be so
proud
as to avoid repeating your peace
placement
sometimes it's better to say recognize
it admit it and then fix it
definitely and uh we see duda
he's a night or specialist as i as i
mentioned
uh previously but we'll see what he does
now i mean if you could get d
five in that would be very good by the
way he did something similar with knight
h5 knight f6 that was certainly not an
admission of
failure remember he provoked g3 g3 is a
very significant and
essentially a permanent weakness of the
king side and that's emphasized with
that h7 he's going after g5 and h3
potentially
wesley can play h4 to stop him but
that's yet another weakness he does
maybe knight back to f6 i know that
sounds crazy but you've done your job
it's it's funny done because i was half
joking about this g4 push earlier
understanding how big the squares would
be and now look what's happening if the
knight goes to f6 will we see a g4 push
i
i had f6 but the other knight that
knight on h7 is there to sort of
supervise the defense uh and maybe duda
is preparing d5 maybe he goes rook d8
wesley trying to preempt him he's trying
to put a knight on d5 that's why he
plays rook c1 so that the c2 punt is not
going to hang
so can you explain to me oh actually now
i think i get it so
the queen was on c7 earlier and if he
had played ac1 that could have been
bishop takes
b3 and queen takes a5 so with the queen
on c6 and the a5 pawn no longer be under
under attack he felt now was the time to
bring the a rook over
because the rook did not need to sit and
protect a5 i was i was
about to ask you why did he play rook d
to c1 earlier
if he's only going to play rook ac one
later but it makes a lot of sense now
that i'm
reflecting that's a great explanation
and now maybe queen drops back to e1
i don't know duda is he trying to go
after t5 here
uh or is he trying to do something on
the king side you know you mentioned g4
robert i'm gonna take a page out of your
book and i'm going to say
dude i might want to play g5 and maybe
he's holding that knight on h7
uh he's saving it for a rainy day maybe
that rainy day has arrived
uh and he tries to turn it back on white
bishop takes d5 and g5 i know that
sounds crazy but
guess what white's king side is so weak
in that maybe he can get away with it
you don't have to encourage me i'm happy
to see g5 and played
and the bishop's already in so why not
g5 next
and then why not f5 let's just push all
these g5 let's go
i think he's going to do it because it's
not that he has infinite time wesley is
saying i'm not sleeping i'm going to go
c5 and i'm going to break open black's
central defenses his rooks are well
positioned to do that
dude has got one moment
and you're probably right about that c5
is
happening very shortly and one thing
i'll keep in the back of our mind is
queen a4
timely queen a4 could be a big nuisance
to white
but for now i don't think it does what
much attacks tonight i'll defend my
knight
good for you so g5 is what i'm looking
at oh
in no small part because you made me and
he's going for e4 is that four
okay that makes yeah definitely and that
makes sense as well
i did like g5 i'm not entirely sure why
but there was something he didn't like
about that duda knows the night or fan
the game of chess a lot better than i do
so
i trust his decision making here
entirely strikes in the center with e4
as you said robert and he's carving out
all of these squares
for all of his pieces this is heating up
but i think black is having all the fun
i agree and magnus carlsen has shown
great skill
in pretty much every position but in
particular in these kind of sicilians
when he pushes e4 sometimes even at the
cost of a pawn
for example this knight we're on d7 you
play e4 and if it's captured you bring
the knight to e5 you're trying to
loosen up white's control over the light
squares and then go forward and that's a
big problem for wesley right now
as duda is about even on the clock as
wesley sits and thinks
about the ramifications of this decision
so dania
it's looking better and better for jkd
as his pieces are coming to life yeah
that's the
that's the night or for you once once
these pieces unfurl
uh there's there's going to be a very
big price depend wesley regretting the
pawn on g3 the pawn on h4
these permanent and long-term weaknesses
are in in a very big way fueling the
fire as he tries to bring you know
life-saving resources to the game rook
to c4
he's trying to get this e4 pawn out of
there on his own terms bringing the
bishop from e2 to f3
uh so that it lends support to these
incredibly weak squares on e4 and g4
will do to preserve the tension play
something like queen f5 uh will he add
more heat to the
to the fire baby bishop f8 uh
essentially involving that rook
on e8 in the attack there's a lot of
options here he also doesn't have a lot
of time
what does he do and this rook c4 not
only does it put pressure e4 and help
out the king side
eventually i was gonna say there could
be a b4 type of minion what
what is going on here oh e3 watch i was
ready
i was about to say it i'm so happy you
said that because my first instinct
because i was thinking about e3 even
before uh dtake c5 i was like can i give
up the pawn
open up the e file and now the point is
that your bishop takes e3
let's bring up the analysis board here
is that there is a hanging bishop on the
square so bishop e3 i can even play
queen takes c6
exactly right bishop takes and your
bishop is hanging
just like mine is we're on the same page
partner
yes indeed i was really happy you said
that because i was thinking about it
you said it we're doing well donya
come on man look at that that's that's
supportive teamwork
that is for i mean i i'm choking up here
you know who else is on the same page
jkd well he's also leading on the clock
in addition to the scoreboard in
addition to the position so
he decides to take with a bishop you
could say he's having a good day
he is having i mean you can just sense
the good form confidence
and you know what's a great indicator of
good form the speed with which we went
into that opposite color bishop end game
confidence to to make critical and
responsible decisions
is an underestimated metric of good form
no hesitation
and accuracy and tactics this is not
looking good for wesley judah has
decided to take with a bishop on e6
preserving the queens
uh which makes sense because the queen
on d7 is very well protected
can he take on c5 wesley hanging by a
thread here
right bishop takes c5 you can't trade
queens first because there's an
intermezzo bishop takes e3 with
check so after bishop takes c5 the
bishop would
recapture it seems but keeping the
queens on the board should be good
for black as white's king is a bit
looser at the pawns on f3 g3 and h4
putting the king in an airy spot
bishop g3 here is interesting by the way
yeah okay so bishop takes g3 the points
if knight takes there's queen takes here
knight takes e4 first is probably
there's a whole smorgasbord of options
here and
now this is collapsing for wesley's yeah
simply knight e4 queen e4
oh the best choice but queen
oh you look at you queen e3 king h2
though it's not over
that look at that king that might have
been a little hasty where is the queen
f2 rookie two though
i mean f2 rookie two but there's a c8
yeah quincy a queen f5
is that oh there's some beautiful
tactics there you queen f5 g6 bring up
the now bring up the analysis board real
quick that way we can show it's a queen
f2
here rookie two if check king h7
and if queen f5 you're saying g6 but i
can take
and my king gets this square to run away
to no but you go 98 after queen
uh c8 i think nope
he's he hasn't done it we'd have to take
a look we're going to tell us
all we'll look now upon down but look at
wesley activating his rook
unbelievable come back robert he might
even be not worse here
and g5 play but that gives the f5 square
that could be critical
as if a knight could land an outpost and
the king could gain some trouble
credible stuff he's showing why won the
u.s championship
this man is not sleeping judo may be in
great form but
wesley so is a monster and now he's
overtaken the initiative four seconds
for doing it he might go g4 now wesley
met that square and n97 also learns
knight e5 as well
very good call so one of those two
g4 oh that would have threatened some
stuff too
okay well now this looks like it is
probably going to peter watch out
don't 1194 tactics gg4 maybe
[Music]
i actually don't like this at all for
black it's looking pretty bad and 1.9
seconds by the way
yep how how does oh okay the time is
going on
how could you point seven seconds it was
going up the momentum
and great defense with no timer's clock
knight back knight c3
oh knight d2 he's he looks like d4 look
at this
king of two he's getting out he's
getting right but rook d3 attacking that
no he goes there
okay rookies think he's got to move it's
like so i'm gonna
it's so close black is holding on for
dear life
it is but look at judah this is their
their knight to d3 is going to come at
night
he's going to establish his knife
attack f4 and there's 19 g5 ideas the
knight goes that f4 so be careful about
that
knight of four knights he's just putting
the hot potato around and white
continues to try to find chances but
look at duda
knight t5 he's not missing any forks oh
that's bad
that's that knight c3 93 that's it king
e6 but is the pawn ending winning f4
beautiful game over f5
and these are the margins with which you
have to beat these guys are we sure it's
over the king has to go to b3 this is a
very famous idea
overextending the opposition king could
not have gone to b5
and now it's winning because king is
credible and the
black king you know has to make a choice
at some point and it's running out of
options
and yep kingston d6
you have made inroads six now you can
king f5 you're gonna pick off the other
pawn or king e6
oh my gosh what a win what a win by
wesley
we are obviously bringing up the
analysis board for that game
because that was a crazy finish indeed
and judah was doing his best to defend
right it was not an easy position
but wesley he put all the pressure on
him and this was the moment here
allowing rook c5 was devastating for
duda he needs to keep his defense alive
but once this knight gets pinned it's
forcing all the material off and
after rook c5 you can't move the knight
knight c3
by the way just a tid but there was a
very beautiful win i think instead of
knight c3 even knight takes g5
robert f4 not that this was necessary
but just pointing it out
you're an evil man but the real question
is was there checkmate
earlier in the game we don't have to
look at that now uh but
duda is definitely going to be thinking
about this as the next game gets
underway it's so hard robert to put
these games out of your mind
we see duda here on camera he
isn't too happy no
he's thinking about it he's lifting his
head up he's trying to remember the
position
he's got to put it behind him and uh i
think he he will be able to
and danya as we know very well from
playing you know over the board
tournaments even
when you have one round a day sometimes
you get a position you're like wait this
reminds me of hess naraditsky from
2016 right we remember our games and so
we're like
wait should i do this or that when
you're playing games back to back to
back to back
you don't have time to get those
thoughts out of your head you're like
wait that game i just played did i miss
checkmate
i mean his king was on h3 was there
something there and you're distracting
yourself from the game at hand
and that makes you honestly play worse
chess most of the time and chess players
are obsessive like that it might
from us from the side and by the way
knight five is is
interesting but uh from the side it
might see well you know what's so
difficult about
just not thinking about it but this is
what these players do
this is what their passion is this is
their obsession and that is what it
takes and it's not as easy as turning an
on and off
switch yeah
and bishop b5 here might try to switch
off that e5 pawn but e4 and queen takes
g3 has to be watched for that knight on
g3 is actually vulnerable
and it's in the crosshairs of the queen
that's a really instructive tactic that
donna's pointing out
the bishop on b6 staring not just at the
f2 pawn but pinning the pawn so
it's not just about the attack also
about the king being behind it
knight f1 the retreating move i'm still
looking at e4 ideas and he plays rookie
at first
yeah he's cooking it up b4 might be very
very strong
white's position is rattling on its
foundations and
due to trying to go after that e5 pawn
it's really the only point of
contact that he has with black's
position it's the only vulnerability in
wesley's position but
there's already sacrifices galore here
e4 yep you called it robert i think he's
gonna
crunch through white's position if he
gets e4 in queensland
maybe to stop it i don't know like does
it really stop it that's the essential
question that i think you and i both
were like
not so sure so he i think that's
actually very smart white it is
has this pawn e5 that you wanted to
target earlier now it's well defended so
let's trade off some pieces
because you know we're getting some
trouble you can't take with the bishop
on e3 that's
a really important point because c3
hangs if you take with the f pawn
how do you like the pawns in the third
rank
i love them they're the best pawn
structure i've ever seen
tell us how you really feel another
awesome time
especially after black plays e4 and
checkmates
yeah fe3 but can he well you know what
dude is thinking about bishop takes c3
saying all right i'm going to give up
the c3 pawn and i'm going to go bishop
c4 check
but nah that's too much and he's better
let's do
this bishop h3 is in the air queen g3
this looks terrible yeah this looks
horrible yeah
you probably had to give up the pawn
there you did i think and he
was correct think about it but i think
he should have taken the plunge
this looks almost lost is there a single
move like knight d4 this bishop takes h3
as you mentioned
h5 there may be yeah but you're just
losing a pawn and then hoping for
compensation right
yeah he's trying to use his knight for
defensive purposes but can you still do
it and bring a rook to f2 for example
and just bring all your pieces in the
attack actually bishop takes h3gh
immediately rook f2 sacking the rook but
that's made if he takes it
oh let's show that let us show that
that's actually that's gonna do it
you are just an evil man
even now sorry go ahead well i'm just
going to show rook f2 it's king takes
there's queen h2 and the rook comes to
fa it's mate
but you're saying rook f2 even now if
you're bishop now bishop takes d5 move
the king away
no too much but that was interesting let
me tell you i didn't see her
i didn't see a direct reputation to it i
don't see it either if i'm being honest
with you but i see that it's plus five
i know folks i know i'm just just
putting it there
probably just take it yeah no need for
that because gh again he has rook f2
it's it's not clear the eval bar went
down after all these moves so clearly
black has compensation in those lines
but he said donya
robert these are my pieces i'm just
going to recap
exactly and i you got to put the brakes
on sometimes say i'm up a pawn i'm
attacking i'm going to go queen g6 here
i'm going to move the bishop away
even to c8 so that it potentially has
access to the a6 square
and uh you don't want to rest on your
laurels here if you're black if duda
consolidates
you know and by the year 2030 that a5
pawn i'm keeping
i'm taking a page out of grand master
hesis book i'm keeping an eye on it
you get into an end game nonchalantly
white goes c4 guess what
pawn on a5 might might be a pretty hefty
price to pay so it's not like wesley is
playing without risk at all he's got to
be precise but
that's what he's going to do i think
bishop takes g2 is is interesting
continuing the trend of giving up pieces
but no bishop
sometimes it's best just to say i got
what i came for
yeah now let me not get ahead of myself
so this move
natural retreating move by the way we
have three minutes
remaining in this time patrol so unless
the game is
decisive in the very near future this
will be our last game
in the longest time patrol yeah and um
queen g3 here is incredibly juicy
but the problem is it doesn't really
threaten anything that knight on h2 i
wouldn't dismiss it
it's actually a very strong defensive
piece because it's covering
the g4 square and that is prime real
estate for the
for the black bishop and it can't get
there so wesley instead deciding to
centralize his queen
maybe c4 he wants to meet with knight c3
getting rid of the bishop duda doesn't
allow it
yeah and the queen was in the same line
as a rook you always have to
be on the lookout for that and black has
what seems to me to be perfect
coordination to pieces
everything is doing an important job now
maybe let's bring this rook up to f6 and
over to g6 he says i'm bringing my
knight back
first and is he going to h5
is she's trying to bring him up maybe to
g4 actually
okay smoke out that knight on
h2 which is the annoying piece and we
just wanted to take a a second to thank
of course chessbra grand masters hanson
and hamilton the ogs for their
very big raid over 500 people joining us
here the speed chess championship match
between
uh wesley so and jan just up dude are
you joining a good time
uh we are moving toward the tail end the
last portion of the five minute segment
we have so much action left
yes indeed appreciate that to the bras
good to see you
and well i'm not sure if jkd is so happy
to see them at this particular moment
because he would have preferred they
rated when he was winning the games
not in this situation where hey this
king is in trouble
white is uh upon down but i just saw the
evil
go up to minus six and then back down to
minus two point seven five
i don't understand why he didn't go in
he four immediately uh
that move looks completely devastating
because if white does not take the
knight
well if he does he gets pinned and
everything is lost and if he doesn't
then rook f2 comes
i think wesley's trying to finagle it
and find the best
moment in time to play knight g4 but i
don't know if there's a need to finesse
this
should he try bishop a5 just to attack
something and
actually if i can get my bishop to this
diagonal it would be a good defender
but your knight g4 is coming no matter
what still yeah but still i mean okay
i agree but still okay i just don't know
what else to bishop e1 maybe just to
defend the f2 square it seems like it
said
everything's yeah i don't see a move
maybe you don't move the bishop at all
but no that would that would that's a
great idea yes let's give up the bishop
and allow an iq four
yeah this look at the time minus four
nine g4 looks really strong but
then rook f1 i think he's found the best
of the worst
because then um okay bishop ah that's
nasty
this is over alright for checkmate
wesley
h5 who's strong downstairs and there's
five seconds left so this game
is resigned right now they would have a
uh one more game nope
so clinical by wesley bishop g4 he just
finds the most surgical way of winning
queen h4 here is just
well then g3 due to trying to give up a
couple pawns and
again let's not forget about that past a
pawn wesley can't just get into an end
game willy nilly that's why knight e5
comes to mind
trying to swing that knight around to f3
that seems like an interesting idea as
well
oh you're you're just a mean mean man he
does this
a brace queen back to each age four yep
and then 95. your your point is very
well taken about this outside past pawn
because if you trade queens that could
end up being a bit of a problem for you
even though black is still doing very
well
he keeps the queens on the board and
trying to trade at all costs yeah rook
d8 rook f4
all right some intrigue left pinning and
hitting e4 and there's a pawn we keep
talking about it
if you trade pieces then i have an
outside past pawn that you're going to
struggle to deal with
yeah definitely and great thing again
wesley's time management has been superb
and he's left himself
quite a bit of time to to think through
these critical moments
but uh yeah he's got definitely some
pretty rook v8 to stop the rook from
moving away from the the first string so
that
because of rook b1 i think maybe rogue
b8 is the key
but then maybe bishop c3
ah e3 pinning the knight because you're
threatening
uh the g7 pawn i could buy that yeah
and what's happening here with the watch
last
taking his time he is up plenty of it
and he traces the last game officially
of the five minute portion
and he decides to go after white spawns
that makes sense yeah but
a5 is coming
yeah no i agree queen okay that's a nice
move because if g6 queen h4 that queen
is trying to snake in here
and you can tell that wesley's not very
happy he's no he's let i mean
this should never have it should never
have come this close but 95 now
finally the knight gets to and that is
crunch knight d3 queen of he's gonna go
after white's king here
yes hanging for good measure
everything's a problem
so high five due to trying everything he
can
i would play queen e2 and then a6 knight
takes d2
and the a6 pawn hangs at the end knight
takes a five
minute five just get rid of that bomb
there must be someone like queen g5 or
something he was worried about wait
i didn't like that their fall queen d3
check
careful now lost oh i thought he lost in
time it was so close
we lost on time this is not clear no it
wasn't clear at all
d7 queen c7 oh my god back in the game
he lost back in the game because he
outside past pawn
oh my lance i know this is crazy but
these positions
can be lost but in a perpetual attempt
there with queen f4 as well
wow wow and okay to be fair to wesleyan
young kristoff wesley was dominating at
home games
even if jkd had some chances toward the
end wesley was still better
and it would have been a tough sledding
for
duda however the score is now four to
four donna any final thoughts before we
head into our break
incredible action both players having
their highlights and their low lights
we expected a close match we are getting
one uh judah showing
amazing form early but some missed
opportunities for both players
they're gonna have to think about their
strategy think about their opening
and they have a little break to do that
i can't wait robert for the three minute
portion
we're going to see these players
reinvigorate and we're going to see
another 60 minutes of incredible
action well we are going to take a break
we'll be back in
a few minutes but for those of you who
are subscribed to the channel you will
enjoy
a prime time smackdown of the one and
only gotham chest taking on
the hammer we'll be right back everybody
i have a little public service
announcement i've been playing this uh
opening
in uh one minute chess since i was 12
years old
and it's horrible do not play it like
this
but it's good enough to beat levi though
you
god that is just so evil that it that
like
i i didn't even have a chance to
concentrate this man just
i was like ready to start okay
this opening it's so bad yet it's so
good i i don't know how to explain it
i still have not fully adapted to this
format normally i am just talking into
my own camp
okay i'm just talking into my own camera
and talking trash against people who
can't hear me
and in this particular case i have
somebody who can hear me
and it's unnerving i don't think i
played that very well
i'm winning on time i'm winning on
position i'm winning on
pretty much every everything you can be
winning in
yeah this format is a bit strange i
already feel like i'm
making inaccurate moves uh-huh because i
have to talk and fill the air time or
else they're not going to pay me for
showing up
and it's like it's just yeah it's it's
it
it's weird like i want to just sit here
and and try to win
and not just be a content farm but
i think i'm just gonna end up being a
content farm that's okay
and then it's like i don't want to talk
on my opponent's move because i feel
like that's a little disrespectful maybe
i'm just gonna do that it's the only way
i can beat hammer
i think definitely will be doing that
i have no qualms about such such things
okay good start you you have no idea how
many times
i have uh won a piece like that you're
you're not the first one to
to drop a fork on the hot how
the fact that you know theory in this is
like even more terrifying
how how can i not know theory i played
it like
you know are we still in theory 30 40
000 times no i never played anything
like this
actually my move knight h6 was a recent
discovery i made
a very a big improvement on the way i
played
this previously
do you have you trained this with magnus
at all
no but i think he's warming up to this
opening because
sometimes uh when he's streaming he will
go oh i'll test out the hammer
oh you know once upon a time when we
were kids
i legitimately consider myself a better
uh one minute player than magnus
i think that's probably still true no he
he got good i don't know
really yeah he almost lost to me once
yeah but he was dominating some some
online
one-minute tournaments he wasn't able to
do that
previously it's like so
slow oh my god yeah but this is this is
my trick
this is my trick so i i will
sin since you're being generous and kind
of just giving me check made in one move
i'll i'll share a secret with you
[Music]
and do not forget to get involved with
guest the move you see
some of the top guessers here
international master venia03 with a
great score and if that were the game
that was selected we don't know what it
will be i believe it's chosen random
that would be a cool 75 bucks in your
pocket so please do get involved
on chess.com live while you follow the
games and
speaking of cool things on chess.com not
cash related but
beth harmon is pretty cash when it comes
to chess now donya i have not
finished the queen's gambit yet i'm only
episodes in still haven't watched more
so i don't know
quite how good beth harmon gets and
there are seven different ages
in addition to 70 other adaptive or
celebrity bots on chess.com available
but i don't know quite how good she gets
so don't ruin it for me but you
should play it's good uh but
you know what i don't know is the
outcome of this current match that we're
watching
i think beth harmon would have loved to
see wesley so and jan schistov due to
duking it out of course wesley the
pre-match
favored by a relatively slim margin
according to smarter chess predictions
we called a close match and we're
getting one robert
all tied up after the five minute
portion and of course we have smarter
chess in the chat saying good start for
duda
and yeah it is good because wesley so is
predicted as a one
game favorite in the longest time patrol
he
was not able to get that lead and so
with that being the case
and as we see here well he has work cut
out for him because the quicker
time controls will favor young christian
well i should say the quickest time to
show because this one
a three game favorite for wesley so what
do you think about that danya
i don't know i and and i explained this
before the match i think that duda has
improved tremendously in uh
faster time controls and it's hard to
factor in the trend
right the trend is something that's less
tangible when you look at the ratings
you look at the results but
as far as i've seen from duda's bullet
games he's gotten faster he's gotten a
little bit crisper in the decision
making
not that he's ever been bad i mean he's
been a beast for for years and
he's he's awesome in every sense of the
word uh but
i think that that might play a role now
wesley again that boa constrictor style
uh can serve him very well he really
knows how to shut people down
and we'll see which of those styles and
tendencies
reigns supreme for sure and wesley is so
strong
at the three-minute segment in these sec
matches that he actually
defeated magnus in that in their uh
match and yeah only that i mean not a
big deal that really indicate anything
though i mean
who hasn't defeated that man just in
everyday occurrence these days
just super exciting but uh in all
seriousness wesley
obviously an absolute force and we are
switching
from a sicilian which we've seen been
played when jkd is black
to now d4 on the first one for wesley so
what do you make of that
opening change by wesley interesting
interesting stuff i mean i think during
the breaks i was going to say you know i
wonder what the players do
i think some players just go take a
breather you know
drink their espresso but some players
they look at the games
uh it's like you imagine that boxing
break you know the coach
tells them the motivational couple of
words here you just quickly decide all
right am i going to keep this opening
when i keep that opening
maybe they look something up really
quickly and that really adds to the
intrigue
because we really see the decision
making of these players in action
uh which i always feel like is awesome
it's a window into these players minds
you can see the wheels turning
wesley very interesting and duda taking
the first long
think uh i'm sure this is theory but
this is a very dangerous position if
black doesn't know what to do that
knight on e4 could get trapped after c5
f3 begin becomes threatened he plays f3
immediately right so the knight does
have the d6 chord which is why you
mentioned c5
and i have played this from the white
side before
so i know that the common idea is to
play d5 for black and i could have been
mixing up my line so
that actually happens even at the game's
very highest levels with players of the
caliber of wesley and
jkd is they know the different ideas but
maybe
a subtle change in the move order or
will say well
the idea with d5 in the other variation
will not work out here so that's why jkd
is just ensuring
that he remembered the right line but
now bishop d7 there could be a problem
with the
knight on f5 hanging important tactic
right
oh that's very interesting and look at
the time and dude
when you whenever you have to move the
king to heaven that is a very bad sign
this is
opening domination robert unless i'm
getting the wrong read on the position
this looks absolutely horrendous but for
jkd
well you're a voracious reader i see all
those books on your shelves you're
absolutely correct here
uh the one issue that wesley will have
to solve is his problem on e3 you would
love to put your bishop on b2
and just aim at the e5 pawn but then you
lose the defense of the e3 square so a5
plate i think that's a very good choice
by young christophe duda here to open up
the queen side
as his king is on f8 which makes his
rook on h8 pretty useless for the time b
right and uh wesley just shifting his
rook to be when you're saying you know
what
yon take that eight file i don't care
about the a file take it to your heart's
content
it resolves the tension now you
mentioned the e3 pawn wesley can resolve
that gradually he can castle go rook d1
eventually he can try to push that pawn
to e4
the problem for duda is just i don't see
how you stop wesley from doing that if
white consolidates and completes his
development
and here we see it due to trying to do
something to
you know to change the trend of the game
but e4
and there we have it he doesn't care
about the past pawn the bishop on b5
doing a great job
protecting the d3 square and knight h4
is trying to be a nuisance but after you
castle where's the attack coming from
four is interesting f4 right saying hey
you're not going to attack me i'm going
to attack you your king's on f8 my
rook's on f1 and dania you called it
here it goes yeah knight g6 might be a
sad necessity here
trying to hold things together yeah he
does it but
man fe and knight f4 even just very
natural play look at the time disparity
as well terrible
terrible position for jkd wouldn't
discount him these people
are monsters at defending and what a
move h3 h3 i don't know if this is a
good
move but it's a move i would not play i
was thinking of bishop to b2
to hit at the d4 pawn another time and
then eventually take on e5 but wesley
just goes
i don't want your knight coming to g4 i
don't want your bishop coming to g4
let me take away that square from your
pieces i know but should be two yeah i
really like that move
i was thinking about something more
concrete but the more i look at this
yeah
you don't want to take on e5 prematurely
because that gives up some squares
so bishop b2 okay bishop c4 stopping
king h7
look at wesley just again the boa
constrictor mentality let me stop
all the threats first but bishop b6 here
maybe he's an interesting defensive
attempt
and he goes for i think you could take
it by queen b3 is
what i'm imagining or queen c4 might
even be stronger
but after uh bishop e6 if you take back
queen into the city
maybe king h7 and at least i evacuate my
king i go rookie eight
you know i'm not sure i think wesley
might have played a little bit too
slowly here
you have a good point that with the king
going h7 even if it costs you a pawn
yep don't forget about this open a file
we like the a5 earlier
and if we start trading off pieces that
rook can infiltrate and i'm with you
diana the pawn
e4 isn't exactly so stable it's uh not
protected by another pawn
i think that jkd's chances have improved
greatly but his time
he's down at 21 seconds wesley taking a
long thing that is perhaps the most
indicative of
of the fact that he recognizes something
has gone astray this move bishop c4 i
liked h3
bishop c4 took it a notch too far i
think he should have went
he should have gone on the offensive now
bishop d3 i like this too he's
preserving the tension
uh based on black stock but f5 now oh
just a winning of peace wow rook b2 i
think duda
yeah not sure just too low on time it's
impossible to defend this and
good job by wesley hunkering down
finding the move and
now he's a peace out do you think dude
is just playing it out to get closer and
closer to that one-minute time control
yeah i think so maybe he's entertaining
some hopes king h7 at least he's made
his king safe it's going to cost a small
price of a piece but
because if this were a classical game he
of course would resign oh totally
and knight and it's not just a piece i
mean look at the dominate bishop on d3
blockading the pawn
white's pieces are perfectly arranged
he's going to resign here i think
he's going to no still bishop c1 queen
f2 by the way interesting idea that's in
wesley's style
we'll make sure to ask the players after
the match but
this is a question that we will probably
continue asking ourselves in the
audience
is young christoph duda trying to waste
as much time as possible
to get to the bullet where that is his
biggest chance he's seeing
the smart chess predictions and he made
sure to exit the five minute portion
even rather than down a game which is
the prediction he wants to
minimize the damage in the three-minute
portion no and these players they
strategize you know they think before
the match right oh bishop
bishop h6 that had some tapatio sauce on
top of that and
uh wesley jumping out a point ahead but
to complete my thought
it you know these players they
strategize they think about
where they're the favorites you know
what they want uh it's not that they
resolve to lose a section right they
they want to win every segment but
they're also realistic and
uh this isn't just yan getting tilted i
think this is all very measured and
thought out
and i agree what i laugh because wesley
was fixing his camera he
knows how to play to the crowd he was
looking at the position and then grabbed
the camera
so it had a better angle so thank you
wesley we appreciate it
looking up at the camera hello wesley
all right
you're allowed to focus on the game now
give us a smile give us a wave you can
hear us no of course he cannot hear us
but
uh about the game we have a position
where we had one pawn trader per side
the c pawn is gone for white giving the
queen on c2 a longer
file the rook on e8 similarly has a
semi-open file to work with
and white has not castled so what do you
make of this dynamic
what are the ideas for black are you
going c5 in the future is that too risky
help us understand what's going on yeah
i mean i i don't know these positions
too well i do think
black deploys this bishop to b7 which
might seem weird
right because the bishop is biting on
granite but b6 as you pointed out has
the
uh alternate intention of preparing c5
which jan uh
prevents with b4 so what's happening
here is i think the battle will revolve
around whether black can play c5 in the
correct version
what wesley can do he can play bishop b7
rook c8 he can still try to go c5 now
yes at the end of the day you'll have an
isolated pawn on d5 but white's pieces
can get sort of tangled up the queen on
the c
file the alternate plan oh c5
immediately here we go here we go
now he's going to try to eliminate that
bishop on d3 and get the two bishop
advantage so very interesting position
i don't know who's better duda doesn't
have to take on c5 but he can go bishop
b2
right i kind of like that wesley played
c5 immediately without putting the
bishop on b7
because the bishop on b7 would have been
under attack when the rook comes to b1
now we can play c4 you can play g6 you
called all of this
and there are pluses and minuses here
the good thing for black
you have sort of protected pass pawn on
c4
the bad thing is that this pawn d5 can
be undermined or attacked
at some point but the biggest issue that
judah is facing is his bishop on c1 you
want that bishop to be out here on g5
yeah hit this knight f6 to get after d5
the bishop's not going anywhere
e4 maybe is a crazy attempt to muddy
muddy the waters but
honestly i do think this calls for
desperate robert i may be overstating
this but if you take the knight on d7
bishop takes dc i think judah seriously
contemplated movie four here because
he's got to do something about this but
uh yeah this is or some sort of other
sacrifice knight d5
uh but this all just this can't work
wesley's disconnected
unless no you're right i see that one
bar
nope he's back okay okay good
i was like we see him still showing the
red bar in my
end of this on my computer but hopefully
we'll he'll be fine
and do it it takes on d7 yep he's back
whoa
g4 g4 in the world is that
i'm taking this
whatever take me take with whatever okay
bishop g4
uh hg knight g4 king g2 oh queen h4
resigns okay
[Laughter]
oh my oh my gosh this looks so tough
this is the most tempting move in the
history of chess
like knight g4 bishop g4 oh yeah knight
g4 also not that dumb
of an idea i think because you preserve
the bishop on d7 it can go to f5 later
i think wesley's deciding not whether he
will take on g4 but which piece he'll
take it with
right and then he takes it oh bishop oh
no that doesn't work okay
that queen h4 coming here it is bishop
f5 at the end like you were just
saying yep okay so there we go
f5 is a threat knight d5 maybe oh bishop
f3 on top of everything else
oh this is nasty
um i'm gonna be honest with you donya
this isn't the best game
from jkd ship f3 by the way yes we have
three queens between me
oh lobster and look at
you know kristoff he's just like takes a
swig of water and he's like nope
not to be outdone and the water theorem
comes into play i mentioned this in a
previous match robert
when and i have to give credit here to
my good friend uh peter
gionatus of the charlotte chess center
he coined this whenever a player is like
comfortable the way match is going you
immediately see whatever beverage
is nearby they're taking that sip of
water there's no
there has never been well dude it just
violated the rule but usually when
you've got a bad position
that water remains untouched
and what a win by wesley but yeah not
the best game for duda
as i see smarter chess making his way
very proud of his prediction
in the chat saying wesley in three plus
one and that's all you need to say
wesley is untouchable it feels like in
that time patrol
even against magnus carlsen so
he's in trouble yeah it's just the right
balance that wesley's able to find right
between
intuition and calculation he's got that
style where he does a little bit of both
and both of those skills for him are so
well developed
judah's gotta put the brakes on this and
and maybe just draw a game with black
uh hit a free throw stabilize and then
it's only two points but he doesn't want
to let the spiral out of control yeah
you and your sports references today
i forgot about thompson i just came back
and i'm pretty devastated
yeah um you know season and can you
believe this
anyways i actually can believe it i'm
not happy about it but it's
terrible he's terrible terrible he's my
favorite player well
behind steph curry but that was nothing
so in other words you lied he's not your
favorite player
no they're they're they're sharing first
place basically and i'm guessing james
weissman is also your favorite player
now that the
warriors okay we'll talk about this
later yeah talk about it the
knight on e5 good piece the pawn on d5
not so good pawn so these seven
positions isolated pawn we've talked
about those earlier
where you want to blockade the pawn make
sure it can't push and trade
off and go after it later in the game so
wesley has
a calm approach he's saying i can put my
queen on d4
and just say that pawn d5 stuck in his
tracks yeah
even d4 might be something to consider
for due to sacking we saw wesley do
something remotely similar in a previous
game sacking the pawn to open some arab
i don't think the occasion calls for
that
but i would consider a way to maybe go
queen d6 something where you
eventually want to absolve yourself of
this weakness the good thing about queen
d6
is also that black eyes the h2 square
he'd have some knight g4 ideas
i'm not saying there's any chance the
black delivers mate here dude is
definitely worse here but
i think he can hold this together he
goes queen f6 okay i want to show
something very quickly and i think it's
important and so we'll bring the
analysis board
just to call attention to it
your idea with queen d6 and knight g4 is
really nice and the one thing i was
going to say is that a really cool thing
for white is you could play with like
queen c7 so just because
mate is under attack doesn't mean you
need to block the attacking piece or
to defend it more directly the queen
protects h2 through the enemy queen
offering the trade taking over the c
file hitting the queenside pawn so i
just want to show that little trick
very quickly i love the x-ray ideas you
know
i'm just trying to be an accommodating
co-commentator so i'm here for you buddy
yeah mostly you're succeeding but we'll
talk about that afterwards
we have some stuff to renegotiate well
the state of affairs in in denmark
uh or in duda's position are not great
he's a minute down on the clock again
that narrative and well where's denmark
come from
it's reference shakespeare reference
right okay
got it you know i'm not really well
versed on my shakespeare at the moment
but no i i've never i trust me i've only
read spark notes but what's the
isn't it rotten in the state of denmark
i think yeah we can we can talk about
you know hamlet and things a little bit
later no i think we should talk about
now all right so let's just be clear
blockade the queen on d4 very happy you
can replace that with a knight knight f3
uh
and i'm getting to the end game where
the knight is very strong the bishop on
e6
is stuck protecting the d5 pawn so not a
very good piece
whereas white's pieces have a free range
oh here's the one
rook b8 might be a sad necessity it is
now the knight's gonna come to b3 or f3
most likely um
probably i kind of like b3 more because
you have
more squares to go to even a5 but if
bishop b5
not allowing the knight to go to e8 to
kick the rook i would seriously consider
d4 and knight t5 just saying all right
i don't care i'm just going to get some
activity for my pieces and i'm going to
get that rook out of c7 i would i would
play d4 here
if i were to yeah how about maybe wesley
goes e4
not even take it just push through he
plays a6 all right maybe d4 now
you can also why you know rook see you
can you get rook c8 in here try oh and
rook b7 and he does it
and then d4 finally and then it happens
tactically and white's in big trouble
exactly so rook c8 is forced now white
preserves in advance but that is a huge
win for black
to trade brooks that this should be a
draw now right king comes to d6
but white is still better because the
pawn isolated
you need to defend it and we actually
saw an end game like this
who was the match it was a dude against
fabiano
where it was light square bishop bad one
versus good one and the bishop came to
b3 and put pressure in the pawn and
eventually e4 was
played i think that was the duda fobby
match and that
as i'm thinking about it you don't want
to eliminate in our minds the chances
that white has here because he is
certainly better yeah without a doubt
and and
26 seconds he's still a minute up on the
clock uh you don't want to fall asleep
here if you're white there's
you know you can let things out of
control f5 is an interesting resource by
duda trying to trade some pawns get that
king out of d4
even h5 the more pawns he trades and he
goes g5 he fixes the pawn on g4
i think he's gonna play one of these
moves f5 at some point maybe knight g6
also for now he brings his pieces into
the game
an idea for wesley to play f4
potentially so
it's hard to generate chances here for
white robert i'm beginning to think this
is just a draw
yeah f4 does invite f5 yeah exactly
you have to be careful if you push too
far it can backfire yeah and this knight
would like to kick the king out but i do
not want to give up the knight for a
bishop that's a really
important point the bishop on e6 is
quite useless and then
white would take over all the dark
squares so knight c6 check would be a
very poor decision
and e4 i thought about that but f6
stopping e5 check
uh and maybe beef i know
could black he's got to be careful here
i know that sounds crazy but he really
does
i was asking the same thing like can
black be better the f4 scale
is blacks for the taking i yeah i know
again
okay he does go b5 i thought bishop d7
but then b takes a6
no bishop a4 oh bishop d7 here is very
nasty
okay he doesn't do it but i guess
there's he takes d5 that's why
yeah you want to keep this point right
as possible
but no you're coming up with clever
shots there and by the way due to down
to 9.4 seconds
he is holding very well he should not be
in any
big trouble but when you don't have time
and maybe one tricky situation arises he
will not have
at f4 though tricky situation or isn't
on the other side
okay wesley trying to distract his
attention maybe move the bishop away to
b7 or something c6
yeah he was bishop c6 and that's what
he's offering a trade
of bishops is knight f4 he goes for it
knight c4 93
the f3 is hanging so you have to knight
e4 check is interesting trying to inch
the king closer
metaphor go so what no
wesley is kind of playing for a win but
he's playing with fire he can be worse
96 check
96 check and then king comes in black's
keeping saving all so that needs to be
factored in
on h5 trying to give this pawn to h4 wow
splitting the pawn jason now he's got
weaknesses all over the place knight
back to f4 bishop five that's what he
wants to accomplish
is have a more active piece but look at
this there's a problem the other side of
the board daniel
oh b5 push going on he takes it bishop
f3 he's got it
he's got a chance now h4 wesley trying
to remove the pieces from the board he's
gonna succeed
he's gonna move if he took the pawn was
king e3 forking
the two pieces so black can never lose
this game but at all
does he have any winning chances not
really yeah
take it take this pawn wow
that was more interesting than it looked
like if you look at that game casually
ah you know equal end game okay they
drew but
there's a lot of tension underwater
there and due to in a certain sense
succeeding and drawing with black he's
got to make something of the white
pieces
and we were talking about this donut
white initially was better because the
isolated pawn
but we saw wesley's are pushing a little
bit too much and wesley knew it
he was very conscientiously saying i'm
going to try to press for win because
judo doesn't have time
i think he understood he was risking
his position as well but now dude with
the white pieces as you just said dania
he needs to prove an advantage here
rather than allowing wesley to have
simple play where
frankly he's the better of the two
players in the three minute
yeah and uh we have another nimso
another variation of the nimzo
and uh this one i don't know too much
about i mean these bishops on b2 and a2
produce kind of an amusing effect
uh they're the kinds of pieces that
could be monsters they could be terrible
i as far as i remember uh wesley well
probably black goes like knight c6 and
at some point e5
to stir things up in the center because
that bishop on a6 is definitely a beast
we know where that bishop is uh going to
be in the bishops hall of fame
c4 first ballot hall of famer there from
right the bishop on a6
not anymore though now the bishop's
closed off so this was
this was in his prime it was bound for
the hall
now it's like i mean you play a couple
more years too though
i don't know about that that's like
carmilla anthony we knew that was going
to the hall of shame okay
she said what are you going after the
trailblazers now they just signed robert
covington and you're going after them
they got dame dollar they they have
trust me i'm just i'm going after a very
specific player oh okay well
i mean cj become the basketball again
yeah what's your fault
so i think it's your phone i don't think
i'm gonna comment to anything
so e5 is the threat to queen e2 is that
yeah but then you pin yourself
against the queen on a6 so what you're
essentially telling me is you don't
really like the isolated pawns on the
queen side for white
and you prefer black's structure yeah i
don't know why but i feel like
i do so dude is thinking about where to
put his queen queen a4 is possible but
every one of these moves is a drawback
na4 brings the queen away from the king
side and wesley's gonna play bishop b7
and then if white castle short he's
going to regret
having the queen on a4 black's going to
go knight g4 all of a sudden that attack
is going to come so fast
this is a very hard decision robert i
think dude is in trouble again and again
he's low on time
yeah i was just showing that very
quickly come back to live position but
it's a very important
point that if the queen gets distracted
all over the queen side
your king is not going to be happy about
the consequences so
he plays queen 2 that's reasonable
protecting c4 another time even though
you're walking to a pin perhaps there's
knight to b5 just
to attack the queen and make c4 feel a
little bit
more defended and danya the bishop on b2
it is now in the open so is that
enough for white or is the c4 pawn so
weak
that oh look at that move oh cb queen 85
move that's right that is that's
technique that is skill right there
playing it really is i love it that is
such a classy move and it puts dude in
such a difficult spot so the idea is c
takes b5
it seems like a blunder right what are
you doing queen is saying bishop is
saying but quinn a5 chuck
and if bishop c3 he can take on b5 but
he can also take on a3
attacking the rook on c1 spoiled for
choice and
just very if we play a little bit more
simplistically now we have an isolated
pawn and black has control
of the square in front of it the
blockading square oh and not just
control but
domination over i mean just total
dominance over the d5 square
duda one should mention has a solid
position these positions are sometimes
overestimated
because it's actually hard to make
progress here in the long run look at
duda's
bot on c5 pawn on d4 well protected so
work to be done for wesley
a lot of work indeed and we talked about
the attack
that wesley tried to drum up in that
game where he
had an isolated pawn rather than the
backward pawn but they
have some similarities right you
blockade a backwards pawn and you put
pressure on it so this pawn d4
isn't the happiest but white's bishop
pair that will give him
chances here now g two under look at
that
look at dude said please take a minute
yeah
you might throw in a g5 absolutely if
bishop takes she's daring wesley to say
country too i don't think he's gonna do
that
because d5 rook g3 now you have two
bishops staring at the
black king side and i know a ton of
arrows but
it's worth it right and again the time
is going to factor in here duda be
well below a minute now i i mean as soon
as this gets tactical that's the issue
it's not when the position remains close
it's when the position gets tactical
just not going to have the time to to
process everything queen c2
now he's got the battery going against
that he can complete the rook left
wesley will have some stuff to deal with
on the king's side if he does that when
he does that potentially
i'm into it and do not take this pawn on
d4 that
okay i thought for a second he did i saw
the rook what if i
don't do it no no he put his work on d5
to actually help
himself out and maybe try to land an
attack and rook g3 of course the bishop
on b2
still defending this pawn and black
to his credit he's really stabilized
his position the bishop on c4 rook on d5
uh
it's not like white can make easy
progress here so
how do you behave well maybe well first
of all the moment the rook moves away
from d5
white's going gonna play d5 he's just
gonna like a shark coming out of the
water
gasping for breath it's you know he's
that rook on d5
it's good but it's also uh holding the
world on its shoulders bishop d1 bishop
f3 is a maneuver that i think dude is
considering here
trying to get that rook out of there
well he doesn't have too much time to
consider things and you know he's got
13 seconds and i do like white's
position
but i trust wesley so as we say rook g4
knight f6 back and forth
i think we're cap three i don't see a
downside to that i know he does go rook
g4
i told you no no you're really you're
looking he's eight
he's eight seconds danya rook f4 he's
gotta decide something four seconds
wesley's not repeating moves is he yeah
yes
see my camera may be doing funky things
today that make me seem extremely beat
right i
don't know what's happening these draw
by repetitions
sadly i've grown accustomed to them i
want to see
action unfold every single time but that
was well played
defense by wesley just making sure he
wasn't getting in trouble and he has a
two-game lead donya so
right i don't think he could have done
much there yeah i wouldn't dismiss that
decision i actually think that the more
i looked at that position
the moment you do something a little bit
inaccurate duda gets his bishops active
and
it could turn from looking good to
getting checkmated in a moment and
wesley again
he's up two points he believes in his
skill he's got
half of the three-minute segment to go
he's got the white pieces he sees no
purpose
in taking what he feels is unnecessary
risk of force i also
i'm a big fan of action but that's
that's the decision he's
he's made yes indeed and now we have
a pawn that can be captured on e5 or do
you capture the pawn on d5 first that's
what he's thinking about
he's trying to figure he takes on d5 and
one of those examples
of a known position but you just want to
make sure that you're remembering it
correctly because you make one
inaccuracy
and all of a sudden white gets the
initiative and you're like okay why
didn't i take on d5 before taking on e5
so he
did do that the bishop one d5 looks good
the bishop on e5 also looks good
will bishop h6 be a thing will bishop h3
be a thing
it's essentially that whites up a tempo
in the entirely symmetrical position
right and uh these are actually very
unpleasant uh
you know it seems it has this air of a
symmetrical position
but it needs to be played with great
accuracy by black uh in order as you
said to not allow this extra tempo to
spiral out of control into an initiative
queen me thinks i like he's kind of
pre-empting queen b3 he's preparing rook
d8
wesley though deploying his bishop to h6
this this thing is heating up
it certainly is and rook d8 looks very
natural here the one
downside of rook d8 is if the queen is
forced away from the defense
there could be a bishop takes f7 check
right because rooks
tend to win the stare down on an open
file when there's a piece in between a
rook and a queen but you can get a
discovery
at some moment so instead bishop g7 was
played looks reasonable if this queen
needs to help the diagonal you can go to
f6 but importantly you're stopping the
queen from getting to d4
dania white is up more or less two
developing moves
at the moment yeah but because there's
no there are no weaknesses right so
that's
how relevant is that lead in development
well
he's got to make something happen in the
next couple of moves because what is
black going to do
he's well knight a4 that's what wesley's
trying because if duda gets his knight
from b8 let's say to f6
okay the problems have been solved as
king is safe so wesley is trying to get
that d4 square for his queen
and judah might want to slide his queen
around to f6 to prevent that from
happening
that however contains its own drawbacks
wesley can then imitate him and position
his own queen on b3
attacking the b7 pawn so duda that
knight a4 is an amazing
sorry to interrupt you because rook
takes c8 there as well
right queen of six rook takes ceo let's
show the announcement
oh no you didn't oh yes i did my friend
hey i'm just stealing a pawn you know
why not i'm just evil i'm a pawn grabber
but knight a4 robert that's the kind of
move you look at okay let's move on
it's actually a brilliant move it forces
black to make a very committal decision
and queen before it you had to stop that
a3 is possible
he's keeping b7 defend and keeping d4
neutral goes queen g4
rook c8 isn't it bike don't forget wait
means coming back
queen c8 that's hilarious but
oh my there's a crazy line but anyways
queen b3 i think is the safe
continuation
but there's so many choices here white
can make what else can he do he can try
to keep the
queen away from g4 you can play f3
although that's pretty weakening
yeah that doesn't come recommended no
definitely not
e4 even but wesley definitely correct in
taking his time here
he senses that this is a moment he could
really press while the iron is hot
he doesn't want to mess this up and rook
takes d5 let's say black and move
would look like a threat because you
take one piece when the queen takes back
you take a second piece
but the issue is your bishop on c8 loses
defender so i was thinking about ideas
with a rook takes d5 the knight not
defended any longer on a4 but you can't
get away with it with this bishop
hanging so he plays f3
who are you donya i don't know
that move looks so bad to me i agree
but he sees something very concrete i
think he really wants to get that queen
of his
to d4 at all costs and he thinks that if
he does that
his problems are going to be solved but
actually queen d4 check i was a little
bit worried about e5
i was worried about e5 here because
queen takes e5 f6
oh and then queen c7 i see also you're
not actually attacking the bishop on d5
because that falls apart that's rook fd1
now
but that knight c6 and there's also e6
ideas you need to keep an eye on
for because uh the bishop's pinned yeah
so
rook f2196 and knight c yeah
i don't know i think knight c6 is almost
forced
okay it's knight c6 you're saying so e6
there must be some tactical flow there
must be
like one five maybe or queen takes d5
so maybe not next queen a4 oh so it was
95.
i was like that was my intuition but but
now it's not
loving it so is it queen guess we're
about to find out
queen's except for that's gonna happen
is there some b5 there no
wait so wesley falling for the same trap
that i just fell for because i see the
eval bar
oh i think it's queen e5 oh my gosh just
pick queen f7 that's it
instead of capturing instead of being
greedy he's from queen f7
and well that's a problem
this is this is a pretty serious problem
i'd say because that bishop cannot move
now wait a minute what is going on here
in the speed of the what what
robert rook d8 is this gonna sustain
itself though
well for on a worst case scenario duda
can play rook a6 rook b6 give the knight
back up
uh and and win b2 i think he's preparing
for that
yes because this is a long journey he's
just going kd6
and then knight d7 if you take on g6 but
the problem is that's too many pawns
and the pawns are fast
it plays b5 i think jgd sees the score
he wants to win but he's six seconds
and i think it's more likely that he
blunders than but i don't know about
that
b5 now he cannot extricate his knight at
all he has no ideas here
but if he e3 if king e3 there's b4 so he
has like one
so that is a as a vicious trick before
you could
even ignore okay wait but this is
spiraling out of control
i almost feel like rotates g6 or f5
first and just pushing these pawns is
good
at f5 and you could even sack something
and get these pawns rolling like f5 gf
ef
king has to go to b7 right you need one
more move about rook a6
this is bad here it comes rook takes b8
there was interesting but instead he
just pushes the pawns
straight through a g6 here just that
easy
just pushing baby push him baby but it's
not gonna be that easy
as it seems maybe you need the king's
support
right because g7 rook takes f7 this is
not over
oh it's so close rookie eight have rook
f8
i'm just trying to be a clown but he was
rookie eight nine g7
oh knight check doesn't do anything
seven uh but this is oh g7 rook have
seven he had some forks uh he's gonna
move but it's over
yeah he was indefensible and
heartbreaking lost
seen there for a moment robert that
wesley had let this out of control but
no
resources coming everywhere in a huge
win extending the lead to three points
now
let's bring the analysis board up
quickly just to show everybody how
wesley not just escaped but even thrived
after
blundering a piece right incredible and
we'll just go back to that moment
real quick here he thought that he had
pressure there were some tactics
queen f7 says well down goes your bishop
but look what he did he gives him a
piece for just
one pawn understanding that black cannot
fully develop because the knight is
pinned
and so as we got forward here you were
right down here rook a6 rook b6
go after the b2 pawn and try to make a
draw but he went for the win
he was all in at this point even if
objectively the computer likes black's
position
now the pawns were taught to defend yeah
that was that
so let's go back to the live board as
wesley
showed his might in that game he is up
eight
to five plus three for wesley so far in
the three plus one
smarter chess looking well for lack of a
better term quite smart
with the predictions and wesley once
again
probably in a position that he's happy
about because i see these
pieces all in line in the center of the
board and there's not even a threat
right now
for white this bishop is not actually
under attack
right and smart chest certainly looking
smarter than
some commentator who shall remain
unnamed who may or may not have
predicted
well something going in dude his favor
but
yeah this position he's got that
blockade going look at those light
squares on the queen side the c4 square
b3 square
duda has control of the center as you
indicated but even c6 would blunt the
bishop on g2 so all of white's
alleged strengths are are sort of dulled
here and and i think blacks again got
the initiative
reeling here is duda and wesley so
confident you could just sense it
complete control over the light squares
blacks uh
pieces queen and bishop lined up these
pawns for white on
dark squares what me what happens if all
your problems are dark squares
the light squares are your opponents for
the taking so
quincy two he's claiming and done let me
know what you think about this that
the three pawns and the c through e
files everyone's just
two pawns dne file so an extra central
pawn
for white is that enough do you look at
this position and say oh i like white's
center or do you see the flow of black's
pieces is overwhelming
yeah so that's a that's a good way to
look at the position now i would say
this uh
in the context of a blitz game white's
got in a certain sense and i know this
sounds crazy but he's got the more
stable position
what does that mean if black messes up
he goes after a pawn
thing spiral out of control white's
center could really make its presence
felt
from an objective standpoint i
absolutely think black is better look at
the and wesley is doing a great job he
didn't take on a4 there
allowing bishop b4 he's going to put a
knight on c4 he's going to establish a
blockade
i think the window of opportunity for
duda is shutting closed
very very quickly maybe bishop b4 try to
get some a5 stuff in
uh so there's stuff to worry about for
wesley he's got to be careful but
objectively i think he's significantly
better here
and one big thing is that black can
actually play e4 file by f5 and close
down
the g2 bishop which is trying to make
its presence felt at some point
and we're talking about the queen side
light squares under black's control that
remains an issue
and if you play e4 for white challenging
the bishop
you're undermining in a sense your own
pawn structure in the center the pawns
are not protected by pawns anymore
they have to be protected by pieces and
that could be a problem
exactly and now due to wow one minute
again it's you know i sound like a
broken record
but it's a huge narrative of the match
uh at least here wow knight b3 i was
going to say the time situation look
again the confidence intermediate move
attacking the rook
does do to have to play rook a2 can he
sack no he does
now mate wesley maybe we'll take back on
e5 or maybe even not maybe he's looking
for something better
exploiting that discovery on the rook
i'd be careful about that though
but then i thought about that but now cd
i feel like white really stabilizes in
the center i'm not sure about that
i agree with you actually and look at
the extra material for black
you get a rook for just a knight in the
pawn
but look how many pawns are in the
center here and
you can't get e4 you would love to play
e4 and d5 now really
continue pushing those pawns can't get
away with it there's nothing protecting
the e4 square
definitely still better for black and
now what wesley can do is take on f3 and
take on e5
exposing the attack on the bishop on f3
and white center collapses i had a
moment of doubt there
but i don't know what i was doing
doubting wesley who was
don't doubt your spectacular chess you
should be confident
i'm confident in you you should also be
confident thank you this means a lot to
me and c5
might make me confident in wesley's
position bishop c6 for
perhaps just to perhaps attack europe
but even there
i think we might see that what's that
guess of the guess the move context
again i think we might uh
contest we might have to participate in
that reference honestly i i've been
looking to see the people who have been
leading indian lad grand master
nice narayan has been doing very well in
it dragon b70
as always and vavr kirk these are like
the three people that are
always at the top of guess what and
here's d5
but now that's c4 but i'm looking at
this diagonal
and you're looking at that diode i am
looking at that diagonal you're also
looking at the file
i'm looking at the f file and queen f3
can happen on the file so
so based on what we just said we just
call it a draw you're looking at one
diagonal i'm looking at another
the other and the diagonals cancel each
other out yeah exactly
five okay he did not like the presence
of that bishop on c6
that's a pretty blessed decision though
i like it though because
black has this past pawn that's much
clearer white's f2 pawn is that really a
pass pawn or is it a target oh that's
only like that because it might lead to
a draw
i did ask for a draw so uh okay bishop
d4
middle i think it's a drop
you're just trying to trade and you you
do have this past pawn but it's not
going anywhere it's
what you're claiming at least in queen
c7 potentially just tying yourself to
the a5 pawn
white's got to be careful i agree but
still
check and back okay
and back so they're just going to repeat
can he brings rook to c8
you can sure try i feel like the thing
is
done if we trade queens right black will
be slightly better in those end games
yeah definitely with a past spawn like
this so no duda
he has to go for the attack on black's
king as weird as that sounds rookie one
i would go for the back ranker and after
h6 maybe try to orchestrate some
h4h5 that's probably too slow okay going
for the activity now queen d1 and c3
robert oh
wait a minute he's gonna play rook c4
and queen c6 so you're just going to
gang up on the pawn
uh anyway or queen d1 just rookie one
but no oh trying to go for an attack
be careful or maybe that looks
f4 oh but now we're back to d8 as
possible and rook d2 oh this is
spiraling out of control
three seconds that's why he he's not
doing well in the club
yeah okay i mean c2 rook c4 no he's
covering
on queen f1 here comes the king hunt
queen f1
forces the king out and where does it go
so he goes he's going by g2 and
he has c2 under control so queen f1 king
h4
i guess and g5 that's just risky
yeah there must be some eight there but
wesley also not a lot of time g5 i think
okay but g5 you could lose that game
king like you absolutely could
but i think you have to do it that's the
only check four seconds for wesley he's
gotta move
all right kg4 right quinn h3 oh let's
make sure queen at five queen five
oh oh he does this king f7 he's gonna
run but there's
oh it takes what com to do that which
there has to be a mate
quick discovery nobody stops him
where does the king go what is wesley
he's six seven king h73 queens
wow what an ending fireworks i don't
think that was that easy after queen
d316 team d7
no that was i mean he's the second time
we've seen that incredible comeback and
he loses on time just when it seems he's
completed it
that was an insane king march
right his king went from g1 into
where to end that one e6 right
wesley shaking has said it i can't
believe i let that king out but
he'll take it and that time management
is paying off in a big way
you know it's done we've made many
sports references thus far and
you take a time out to gather yourself
in chess when you time out
you just lose the game so unfortunately
for
jkd here he has not found his footing
in this time but he is down four points
right now and
we know how talented it uh don yeah you
too
you also are very bullet but duda is in
the one plus one he beat fabiano eight
to one in that time control that's
ridiculous
but something about wesley so there's
something about
him that just is kind of due to his
kryptonite
no he's just he's just good and he keeps
the pressure going and by the way this
d5 move that is a trap actually
wait where was i falling into
again sorry no you're good there's if uh
e4 ideas is down his point but
wesley got up from his chair and i'm
hoping he's bringing this cat
that's what i'm looking for i haven't
seen wesley's cat actually
wow i i do like that chair though i
think we should analyze that
that's a pretty good idea so yeah duda
is just
he's reeling and as you said wesley is
playing all of the games at once the
time game and the chess game
and he's not taking his foot off the gas
pedal it's not that wesley doesn't make
mistakes he does
but when he makes them he doesn't make
them in pairs he recovers
he keeps the pressure going and it is
producing some excellent chess here
and once again duda is down quite a lot
of time here and you said you've walked
in this e4
yep so you have three pawns for the
piece
yeah but it's not enough i think the end
game end game is good for white
uh and i'm pretty sure well wesley's
thinking about taking the knight on c3 i
don't
necessarily think he has to i mean he
can take the queen and just drop his
rook back
and it's hard for black to coordinate
his pieces uh and he might end up losing
one or two of his pawns
yeah i mean this bishop on g2 sort of
catalan style bishop
always strong diagonal and you will have
control over the light squares but it is
three pawns dania says
you have a difficult time defending i i
totally buy that
but i don't have experience in these
lines i'm just counting the material
looking at the position
white is better how much is the
essential question
yeah uh not winning for sure uh but
duda's got to be very precise i think
queen takes queen
would at least take the heat off of the
b-pawn give black a tempo which he uses
to bring his rook into the game
well he says no no no you're going to
defend that pawn and the move b6
it creates a structural weakness that
leaves the c6 knight undefended might
not seem important but guess what
that catalan bishop your reference that
could make its presence felt as well
and the problem for black is
when you have extra pollens you want to
start mobilizing those pawns
but white is the one actually attacking
the a7 pawn if the a7 pawn moves to a5
then b6 is weak now knight somehow
you know i wouldn't think this would be
an essential pawn but this a pawn
having the ability to play a3 at some
point to make sure the knight doesn't
get into b4
is really important because otherwise
black could play a5
in knight before himself right that's a
great point
every little detail is significant
wesley
creating a g5 square for his knight with
a move h4
very classy due to trying to cover up
all of the bases here but you can see
he's hanging on by a thread that knight
from g5 can come to e4
and then the b6 spawn is overloaded he
can take on c5
this is exactly what i sort of thought
might happen you know with with black's
pawns he's got a lot of them but it's so
hard to sustain them
robert this is looking very bad you're
totally right
94 takes c5 a nice threat of course
you'd like to take this bishop as well
so what if i put my bishop on d4 i know
i don't want to give up my opposite
color bishop
the dark soul bishop with control of the
whole diagonal but if you take me and i
can take with the c pawn don't i get a
pass pawn to work with as well
that's a that's a great call i think
bishop d4 has to be played
you know whatever the objective
evaluation and he's got to play it very
fast again he's down a minute
he's trying to put his bishop on e7 but
i don't know that's also interesting i
liked your idea though active
yeah this is a bit more passive you
can't play f5 later right with an
e4 to kick it and he goes for this so he
doesn't want to trade pieces
and maybe that's a reasonable choice
wesley
dania look at the clock wesley well
ahead on time here it's the story of in
many ways
it's one of them not to take away from
his uh superb play but
it just adds to his mastery that this
management of time it's so
not too fast and not too slow it's just
perfect he always leaves himself enough
time to think through the critical
moments
knight to c3 what is his idea how does
he break down black's defenses he
doesn't have forever
due to deploying his pieces very nicely
yeah and
how do you get this a7 pawn again well
you don't just black is tied down this
rook on d7 would love to start moving in
to d2 for example but you drop the a7
pawn once a7 falls down goes b6
so black tied down here white sort of
tied down as well
who is going to get the upper hand well
rook d1 is possible he can swap a pair
of brooks
the question is is that a good thing
they're delaying wesley delaying on that
for now
duda can just buy it his time but even
that's not easy to do does he have a
king g8 or something it's not easy to
make a single move
how about f5 just say the heck with it
i'm getting
active i like it he's 20 so you're just
gonna move
you can't think you gotta make a
decision come on young kristoff not that
we're rooting for either player but
it just feels like this is a trend that
we need him to fix for his own sake
exactly knight to c4 he's trying to
dislodge the knight from a5 he's using
the opportunity black has left the
defile
he has a moment in five seconds robert
they're just impossible to play in this
position
okay he's attacking this this rook is
trying to come down d2 okay
works not getting to d2 knight c5 is
possible but then rook d2
but look he's giving up his bishop i
think the bishop on d4 earlier
would have been a better placement for
it but he's been playing fine
it just now you can't take it if you
want but i don't think that
wesley does because the knight covers d2
as well it's only a matter of time
no pun intended is horrible
wait wasn't it is that a repetition i
feel like they had this before
we mentioned knight takes c5 he didn't
play it and okay bishop
attacking this knight back
one second oh we barely got to move off
okay but nigel i mean wesley has so many
ideas here look at him just tightening
the screws
in one point three seconds what do you
mean he's gonna flag
it's sad to see because he's actually
defending really well robert he's
actually not letting wesley make that
much progress
and duda just puts his hand out shakes
his head and it's like
what hey i mean you have one second for
many moves throughout this match you're
going to be losing on time unfortunately
well something that's in i noticed and
not to be the monday morning you know
armchair general here they both of these
players had
put me to shame in the opening but i
feel like wesley is just better prepared
it seems like in a lot of games
there's a position in the opening where
duda takes
45 50 seconds in the five minute portion
that's kind of washed away by the
time the three-minute portion that's
what sets things off
that's just one thing no you i mean
you're right you also get
in some sort of comfort zone in five
minutes you start playing eight games of
five minute
i can spend a minute on move 12 if i
wanted five minute because i still have
three and a half minutes after that a
time has been used but when you're
playing three minutes you spend all the
time now you're down to
55 seconds to your opponent's two
minutes and you just don't have time to
calculate
when the action heats up right exactly
and
here we see again move 11 duda taking
his time wesley over two minutes 50.
and again it's the same this is what i'm
saying there's that moment in the
opening he takes a long time he's out of
theory it seems wesley's still in prep
and wesley has also been doing a good
job of looking at the
match timer so he's trying to probably
strategize around that as i don't even
know how big of an underdog wesley will
be in the bullet
but i would definitely not say a
five-game underdog and that's what his
lead is right now
but he has been keeping an eye on the
match clock and he has experience to
know
if this position say looks level do i
just make a quick draw so i get another
game in or
you know the position is slightly better
for me let me just play it out i don't
mind getting into the bullet
as long as i can maintain my lead so
that's what you have to keep in mind
as we get ready for the final segment of
this match
indeed and look at the time but in terms
of the bullet if we look at the ratings
well yes dude us
32 30. wesley at these are crazy
3004 but that doesn't again that just
doesn't tell the whole story i don't
think wesley plays that much bullet
uh on chess.com and oneplus one we've
talked about it many times
we'll discuss it again uh before the
bullet segment
uh but that changes the dynamic of you
know of the games of the match because
it really adds that element
of thoughtfulness and takes away some of
the crazy time scrambles but here duda
he's almost below a minute that's a
crazy time disparity he's down a pawn
i don't know he might be worse here as
well
that's clock situation i was doing
knight to b5 he
is going after the a7 pawn knight c7
traps the rook or doesn't wait there's
rook c8
pinning the knight so there are some
ideas of course in the position he has
the bishop pair
but daniel feels like he's playing this
out of more desperation
than actual strength yup and knight c7
rook c8
such a tricky wesley always finding the
opportunity to
pose problems to his opponent force him
into a decision black is better
i don't think white white is enough for
the pawn robert i
it's just looking bad again
wow just not even easy to attack there's
no bishop h3 to go after e6 that makes
sense
but when i see a move g3 done i
immediately think 95 and
knight into these weak squares he plays
g4
and uh now he can absolutely take the
bishop fix the pawn on the dark square
due to trying to deploy his pieces
actually h5 is interesting he defends
the night with that f6 instead
so confident so fast and and so strong
all around amazing play here and dude
i'm not able to stem the bleeding
black's pieces perfectly defended
white's pieces look good
they're not accomplishing much and as
you said h5 to defend this knight on g4
even if it gives you a second
set of double isolated pawns you open
the h file you're trading pieces you're
in good shape
you are and 20 seconds now judah's just
he's he's just not yeah he's shaking his
head he
can't can't find the zen uh it seems
like each each position is just not in
his
style and wesley's able to channel these
positions into his
territory of preparation and this is
yeah this is looking very bad again
i i wonder what's going on with duda
though because there have been moments
throughout
like right now his vision is
particularly bad but he's spending a lot
of time he's gotta move
it doesn't feel entirely necessary so i
just don't think he
he has the confidence that he had to
start out the match he was up two games
early on really yeah he was let's not
forget that's how he started he started
with a bang
and he was playing amazing and then just
something
gradually happened over the course of
the five minute portion which continued
in the three minute portion
that's right and i'm glad to see so many
people here
we have over 16 000 people on twitch
right now
always good to have such an audience and
yes i am keeping my right eye on the
chat and my
left eye on the game so traitor pieces
so an extra pawn still
for wesley eight seconds left for young
christoph do you trade rooks
and get into a minor peace end game
where you have a knight
which means you can go from color
complex the color complex and the bishop
can't no he goes straight forward
we're going to keep the rocks robots you
know you're going to keep the rooks in
here try to throw your crucible
knight d5 now he's got black tied down
white side down rock five is coming
oh and so methodical
right that's the word that comes to mind
thorough methodical doesn't rush
activates all the pieces and uh just
torture here for
yon i feel for him
i feel for man it's just hard to make
moves at this point it is
and at the very least wesley with five
minutes left this will not be the last
game
uh this will be the penultimate game and
does duda have chance to hold he really
cannot afford to lose this game
three seconds if if he had a little bit
more time i would have said yes
the knights jumping around hither in 95
knight f3 d3 there's so many squares to
account for
uh doesn't matter who it is it's almost
impossible not to blunder eventually
yeah heather and dither will make
do the shiver i guess that was pretty
good
i was like trying to you know i was uh
trying to come up with something there i
was wondering where you were going with
that
well i was yeah i was gonna whatever
we'll talk about that later too
yeah exactly seems like we have some
stuff to discuss
okay so wesley oh king e5 just total
domination rook c1 rookie one mates
and i'm just shaking in my head g5 is
just nope
not a single move just taking the air
out of him
one more time wasn't rook c1 rookie one
made well rook c1 bishop takes c4 and
then the pawn end game was winning for
black which is the original idea
let's show you played we'll bring up the
analysis board
yeah so rook c1 bishop takes e4
king e4 rook takes d3 so you sacrifice a
bishop for pawn to win
the knight but after rook c2 dania and i
were thinking this is just winning
because if you're active king
and you can just go start taking pawns
yep or e5
anything wins there wesley uh singing
is he pulling a parham or well what's
probably on pulling a wesley
pulling a wesley means playing
exceptional chess
and having a very lovely cat
who joins you for interviews and what
else
being super humble how long i'm just
throwing out all the
things about no he's awesome wesley is
he's a class act and he is
he lets his moves do the talking and
that is the hallmark of
a true professional and uh that's
exactly what wesley is he's he's
been amazing for a long time and he's
putting that on full display here not to
take anything away from
jkd he's still very young he's so
accomplished and
he's trying his best here we feel for
him we don't root for anybody
uh but this is just an amazing display
by wesley
and for duda he is down six points and
he played
a line here in this kind of bononi
structure
and his pawns on g5 he's the pawn d6
that will
you'd be tended to not ideal he's
tilting
donya i i feel pretty strongly that he's
just yes yes
angry at five square and benoni there's
certain openings that
they're not bad but you just don't
really play them unless you're kind of
like alright whatever
not that he has a terrible position here
but definitely not what he was looking
for
well he wanted to play f5 and swing that
rook over you're not getting an f5 when
all of these pieces are stopping that
pawn from
pushing right this isn't good man
this is not good it's a sibolita's
balloon to six
again duda as we've referenced the
crushed fabi
with a seven point margin in the bullet
so we won't rule anything out but
he needs this break robert he needs it
really badly
i'm just trying to figure out what he
can do in this game and he's about even
on the clock so that's the good news for
him
but the problem is he is struggling in
both
areas of the board right center is
closed so the both arrows means
the king side you have to keep an eye on
the g5 pawn the f5 square
the queen side the a6 pawn will need
some tending too
the b6 square could be loose after a
knight c4
uh for not bishops or knight c4 you
could also get a
b4 type of push in that's thematic and
white's king is
going to be safe no matter what and you
can also castle you could keep your king
in the center with kiwi too
you're spoiled for choice i was just
thinking about what wesley's singing it
sounds like an opera of some sort i feel
like wes leslie's opera
kind of guy you know it sounds wait you
can hear him no
it just looks just the sort of
expressiveness and i don't know the
motions it doesn't seem like a eminem it
seems more like
i don't know giuseppe verdi or something
we'll have to ask him later whoa
what oh you see wesley just like i
thought he was
looking wait well he seems that way but
he has an amazing position and he's
upset but yeah i saw that shake of the
head
maybe he's saying the wrong lyrics
let's say his position looks good so i
don't know what he'd be upset about here
maybe a song came on that he didn't like
well well well said daniel that was
funny he fell into a mondegreen that's a
word i learned recently
why is he so why are you shaking his
head and you with your
fancy vocabulary no it's i i was i
didn't know this right
but that's what it means it means a
lyric that is commonly mis
mis-uh cited right like in a song you
think it says one thing and
really it says another thing how would
you just uh
you know teach people maneuvering
i don't know are we supposed to be
commentating any something else i mean
why did they hire me i thought i could
just discuss this look at the c file
queen to c7 is coming in
yeah this doesn't look very good no i
i'm actually appreciative that you
taught me that word i
now will undoubtedly use it incorrectly
and i i do enjoy
miriam webster you know so my boy miriam
[Laughter]
yeah you know what else is my boy the c
file
and this is this is very very ugly this
position is
a just a catastrophe for duda
yes this doesn't look uh so nice
d6 is a weak f5 still problem the c file
under white's control
wesley singing having a better time it
looks like now sax the exchange but
queen d6 even mcqueen d7 and
he's just mowing vacuuming up the pawns
and blacks knights stumbling
against each other and the rook on c1 is
not doing anything
it's a very nice idea by the way sacking
the exchange here i like it a lot
and king issue perfectly safe the king
on h8 may find itself in harm's way in
the near future
but for now it's just all wesley
i'm out of words i'm out of words yeah i
mean this again
uh to reiterate we you know we we want
to see great chess we love both of these
guys
i can be painful to watch uh
this sort of thing happen but at the
same time we have to give tremendous
credit to wesley he's been
he's been amazing uh for lack of a
better word takes g7 so
measured so methodical and universal
and here he trades off as two pieces for
the rook he's a past
d-pawn for good measure and it's not
actually that
easy at least right now to see how the
game concludes
but it's clear that white it will
conclude yes
it certainly will conclude there's no
choice in that matter but my point is
that sometimes we think oh to my piece
against a rook obviously that's winning
and you start looking wait if i get a
king f6 a knight f7
is it that bad yes yeah that's a great
question the minor pieces can have a
very hard time supervising
a past pawn all the way to promotion
particularly as you said in the presence
of a rook
which is why wesley's sort of trying to
stabilize consolidate maybe get the
knight from e3 to d5
and c7 yep
yes and he gets that one that's a better
pass spawn because it's protected by the
other one now knight back to c5 and
yeah judah's done a fantastic job here
resisting bishop d3 though tying the
knight down to the pawn
looks like wesley's going to grind him
down one way or another
indeed and what
wesley wants is bringing this other
knight into the game and he plays wait
oh that was a chance now knight c3 yeah
that this looks
better than the next either still my
digital still
okay blind spot for both players yeah
bishop 84 by the way that might be a
nice little win
oh you
i'm not gonna finish my thought but you
ugh i know that's
that's the perfect descriptive still
bishop a4 i like bishop
how about 96 king h4g3
put a piece in a4 there it is there we
go rook c3 though oh no no g
i thought g3 checked but the king has h3
square
well young christophedo will be thrilled
to be done with the three minute portion
um i am probably looking about as red as
duda feels
but dania what a performance by wesley
so
absolute domination every game every
position
preparation middle games tactics
positional chess technique
worst positions he pulled it off this
way and that way and the other way and
on
top of that amazing time management just
a tour de force
but we still have 30 minutes of below we
know what dude is capable of robert so
i hope nobody's going anywhere because
there's still some intrigue left let's
see if there's gas left in the tank for
jfk james jfk oh my god
wow that was a yeah okay so
for duda he did beat five minute car one
eight to one in bullet this is
a seven point lead for wesley so on this
wild note we are gonna send it
send us the break but we will have more
of the prom smackdown
no between gotham chess and the one and
only you live hammer
if you're a subscriber please enjoy that
otherwise enjoy the ads
[Music]
okay my entire one minute strategy is
going into an end game
and i i just know that in an end game
i'm gonna win
okay yeah i feel like strat though i
feel like this is
well this is like going up against
khabib it's like you know what's gonna
happen
there's nothing that you can do about it
i i'm i'm familiar with that reference
uh hammer what can we talk about
tell me what the reference is like
sports
i i like sports yeah i like soccer the
best sport in all of the world
aren't you norwegian aren't you like not
supposed to call it soccer
uh i lived in the us as a kid so i i got
into bad habits wow
never recovered from saying soccer
that's
that's pretty uh uh
okay where'd you live in the us berkeley
california i feel like this is way too
polite for the smackdown
i know you know it's just i feel like i
feel like you need like a degree of
comfort to engage in like vicious smack
talk and i just feel like we've met like
a few times you know
i i can't really sit here and be like
yeah no that's my superpower
i'm just too nice people don't you know
they
they are they're afraid to help me
um not too happy about losing all my
pieces but
what
yeah now i have to like buckle down here
and try to
[Music]
actually focus and not have you flag me
which is or or that
so this is my strategy the end game
always works
okay yeah it was a blunder by me but
it works out kinda
wow no way you just did that i
i dirty dirty man
oh i'm actually losing on time
no way you did that as well that was an
accident that
that was unintentional
okay no more mr nice guy for me i grew
up in uh
i guess i grew up in new york city if
you want to keep talking about childhood
okay this looks this this looks pretty
decent for me from the opening
yeah no i mean the entire opening is
just horrible it's horrible for black
but somehow now you close down the h
file and i'm just better
you think you're better here yeah of
course i am
good control everywhere
i feel like i'm i feel like i'm creating
a little bit of uh how is their meta
the thing is when you play an opening as
bad as this
when you're equal you pretty much feel
like you're better
that's the advantage i see that's fair
see i i never make it to that phase of
the game generally when i'm playing so
aren't you just aren't you just like
actually just worse now
we're we're discussing some serious like
meta strats here but uh
it's bullet it's bullet it's bullet oh
that that that is good that is good
that's nice and positional there's my
style
um
so
well look what we have here donya the
cat's meow
it's made its appearance finally
this stream wouldn't be complete without
it this commentary wouldn't be without
that adorable image and uh
wow you know you don't sound like a cat
person based on how you're reacting i am
no i love cats what are you talking
about i love dogs and i love cats
it really sounds like you're a cat hater
based on how you're talking right now
what's up i'm going to tell wesley i'm
going
to let him know almost going to agree
with commentating in the next time but
you just forfeited that opportunity
the cat i mean the cat is live this is
live footage of wesley
oh adorable oh bring the cat back
yeah where's he going
okay well now we're gonna be back to the
chest wesley so has a
seven game lead and as you can see on
screen look at the avatar next to wesley
so's name
right down over here that is that's a
cat
wow now i understand i actually i didn't
know you had a cat
before today's match i'll be honest
well now you know and the cat makes a
very frequent appearance
on wesley so's um matches
right yeah definitely
are you trying to rub in the fact that i
didn't know you had a cat
not really but so you are a cat person
no i mean i i like cats and i like dogs
like i'm not one of those people who
runs away when i visit someone and they
have a cat or a dog
gotcha like i wouldn't necessarily spend
an hour petting them but
you know i'm somewhere in the middle
don't worry a cat will not let you spend
an hour
it's okay much less than a minute that's
that's what i've heard
yeah i mean the thing is i never
understood what we can have this
conversation later as well people are
like i'm a cat person or a dog person
you could be both it's not that hard
anyway chest chest chest look at jkd
look at jkd he's back in his chair
i think the problem for him right now
besides the seven nothing deficit
so nothing seven game deficit that he's
facing he needs to
start winning like he doesn't have a
choice to make a couple draws to
get himself in the you know heat of the
moment ready for the next game he needs
to just go
he needs to be out there at sacrificing
pieces
playing very quickly donnie can you do
it can he win by seven against another
super grandmaster
one game at a time it's a cliche but
he's got to win this first one 30
minutes
let's remind everybody there isn't an
hour there's 30 minutes of bullet there
is
enough time to play over seven games
there's about eight nine games
uh somewhere in that neighborhood which
leaves his margin for error practically
zero robert and he yeah he needs to win
game after gaming to forget about the
lead and say okay i need to win this
game
wins this game i need to win the next
one put everything behind him it seems
he's done that
let's see how he fares yeah he's
going for it that's the way that's the
way to do it now wesley of course is not
just going to let him
checkmate him that easily he did take
though and he opens up the
uh the g file careful knight f check
right that's very important because you
would like to take and then take and
then open the whole board up
but there's knight f three check at the
end of things when this knight gets here
right again he wants to get knight take
d5
maybe you have six to cover the bishop
blunt the no whoa
that is bold okay
that looks strange to me rook takes e7
and knight f6 is a threat with those
kind of ideas
nice wesley trying to create that
tension along the sea i don't think that
helps though
if he takes because bishop e5 is still a
threat you lose your queen but then you
take on g7 you make oh
nice in the windmill wesley is not
happy now he's got a small you know
he's he he's up seven points so he can
okay rookie seven rookie seven
all right guys sorry i missed it
beautiful night of six
i was calling for it earlier you you did
you saw it immediately
f4 though still winning yeah this is
still looking great for dude
that was awesome this should be five now
bish should be five rook d7
oh insermento not so flow
fish should be six and knight takes e4
three pieces for a queen oh bishop f8
first even
yes that's nice so now two minor pieces
and a rook for a queen you know robert
from my experience in bullets
specifically
this can seem winning it's very hard to
play against the queen mark my words
it's very hard to play against the queen
where do you want me to mark them let me
know i want i have an idea of where i
want
to play i have several thoughts about it
i have a pen
so i'll mark them i have a pencil wait
why is our king on d2 so
the rook was sacked for the bishop the
king is
out in the open plenty of checks
yeah you're right though wesley's got
good chances here no yeah this is and
there's so many squares to queen e2 is
almost mate queen e2 queen f2 for
example and you start
mopping up the pawns right that's a lot
of puns
queen h2 i mean you can just start
vacuuming up turn the dyson on and just
take him
but look at this bishop takes b6 and
then white has a pass pawn
right yeah well i don't know who's
pushing
robert i think black is also pushing
they both are the bishop on f3
multitasker
stop being with a8 there's knight c6
ideas right to stop that bishop from
uh queen g keeping the a square under
control so maybe queen g two to stop of
that
but then the h bond is progressed
bishop c5 is similar b6 b7 he's just
going to push the pawn slowly
yeah the gates have opened e4 he's got
to try but
i don't think that works but this was
close i mean i'm telling
this took a lot of time off of the match
clock but he can afford that
as long as he carries this home was his
game
but i think white's going to win yeah
queen d2 now king is safe
lacking is safe for now but not for very
much longer
now sacrifice some of your extra
material trade-off pieces
and five queen g2 nice queen g7
bleeding the clock which is fine 27 made
pre-move
pre-move it and he's going to flag him
that is a win for
jkd and he did miss that tactic earlier
and of course his bullet chest
things are going to be missed but he put
together a complete game
and that's what he needs he started off
on a good note dania
can he get two three wins in a row now
this game
this is the crucial game six has a
different ring to it than five
wesley is so solid with white even in
bullet we have a slav
slob is a good opening that you b5
they're sort of a structure this
is a very combative line
wesley is well prepared here this is
super theoretical he's got to not get
caught up in preparation
it's weird to talk about prep and bullet
but the stakes are high
they certainly are and i agree with you
duda should not be venturing into
theoretical waters
and he needs to make wesley think and
then out play him but
it's very difficult to do outplaying
wesley freaking so but it's possible
and he just should not be going into
theoretical territory where wesley has
seemed
better prepared in this match yep and he
is again again we see and obviously dude
i'm not thinking for as long as he did
in the three-minute portion but i think
he's in huge trouble already look where
is that night going
good night oh my lands and again and
again he's just getting in trouble in
the opening wesley's so well prepared
he's dead i think lost for black oh
mm-hmm yeah maybe some chances but look
at this such a nice
move it's like an intermessage that
isn't even necessarily
urgent needed but he does it and
why are you not just taking on enough
sick h6 excuse me well he's thinking
about f4 i think
he might be contemplating whether to
play nope just takes it and i like that
okay judah manages to more or less
stabilize move the rook away
but um wesley can try to get his queen
to g5 potentially
cost him a pawn but the king on h2 isn't
the safest king in the world he gives up
the b-pawn
he's going through it he's going after
e4 this is queen b6 threatens some kind
of night discovery oh nice knight g4
ideas
yeah one though he's trying to get
knight g4 here as well that's not gonna
work
knight e4 and bishop before bishop g3
wesley brings his rook and he saw it
a queen h4 is definitely on the dock
definitely
oh now you can't yes now some my
discovery ideas but
i don't see anything specific i really
want to put that queen on h4 but he's
refraining from doing so
well bishop takes g3 is a threat i would
sack on h i would just take on e4 twice
give up that bishop on h6 potentially no
he keeps it bishop a6 though
okay so you can win in exchange for the
queen 65 gets the queens off
the queen he ordered the queen
what does he think he doesn't take him
oh he missed me
oh my god my dude shakes his head has
wesley not seen it
he didn't see it wesley didn't react
yeah no he didn't see it
oh my lance oh and it's this bishop
on f3 you know that could be a meeting
net but it's still over
well it's honestly wasting more time
unless he did it on purpose
that would be next level he didn't take
a freak no that goes against such
base instincts that i don't think even
if he wanted to do it that's like the
well we'll pull up the uh analysis board
real quick just to show that one more
time because
i was like am i missing a pin here no no
no
you were totally right bishop e3 where
the bishop was
was here it moved back queen h6 and the
move bishop takes h6 was not played
what was the idea of queen hd can you
like let's forget about the
what is he threatening
[Laughter]
you're asking the wrong person you're
asking the wrong person
well unfortunately for jkd we get back
to the live board here
he is now down seven once more not too
much time on the clock
and for wesley you're looking at this 22
minutes left
that means there's still time for jkd
to win every single game and tie the
match
but the clock's ticking against you now
right well we've seen
katie pull out some comebacks in
basketball will jkd pull out some
comebacks and chess
i was i've been roasting that like pot
of bad coffee for the entire commentary
yeah i'll forgive you eventually but
people are suggesting hey maybe it was a
mouse slip you want to go to g6 instead
of h6 and maybe that
potentially was the case didn't look so
good for black regardless at that point
but when wesley started to think i was
thinking is he going to miss it
i thought maybe he was just bleeding the
clock before taking mcqueen
and it is possible that if that was a
mouse slip he was just being
very kind saying oh he slipped i don't
want to take his queen here but
it wasn't kind in the end because he
mopped up all the pawns in one
right and now not a position conducive
to too many winning attempts wesley with
the strong bishops
and the open d-file controlled by him
yeah this just doesn't i mean
duda is is a fighter he's going to fight
to the last drop of blood but if wesley
can get another one here
that makes it very very unlikely rook d3
is possible as an intermediate move
that's very nice plant that rook on the
square you can also put the bishop back
to
no longer back to b5 but let's say king
e2 you had bishop b5 check
and here comes the rook yeah b5 or
bishop
a3 i mean so many attempts f5 even
like f5 just go for the center mm-hmm
king e2
probably necessarily then even e34 and
his rookie three check
look at those bishops just cooperating
all of the p wesley always has
such well-coordinated pieces i know it's
again it's a trivial
statement maybe but so healthy in his
pawn structure the way that he arranges
his pieces
he's a little good at chest i don't know
if you know can you take that you take
enough three or sixty about that too
wait you think you might have been able
to
huh taking on f3 seems
nice i guess and i'm just trying to
sacrifice the pieces but yeah look what
he did he put his bishop on d5 bishop
one c5 rook on e3 the guy plays
perfect chess sometimes where all of his
pieces
are optimally placed and his opponent is
just struggling to come up with ideas
he sees everything he's a machine as
someone tends to say
yeah this is so the
evo went down but it wasn't because he
won
well he didn't make the most out of this
but now he's got the pass pawn and again
he's bleeding more clock so he doesn't
even really need to win i mean as long
as he
even makes a draw yeah
but due to very nice defense here you
sort of stabilize the situation
knight on e3 doesn't look so good no
and offering the exchange of bishops see
that's just
it goes to show right down here that if
you trade dark square bishops
you're not gonna make progress because a
light square bishop can't attack dark
squares and
their inherent limitations to the pieces
this is just
a nightmare not lost now yeah i mean
with two seconds on the clock king's
i mean wesley is so many it's bishop d4
stopping every threat
if you notice it can be easy to miss in
the heat of the moment how he's just
strangling him i mean not a single idea
he allows and
that playing style has is uh a rare
sight nowadays
well not really but wesley takes it to
an absolutely different level
epic that's why he's so hard to beat
because he is an extremely precise
player
oh okay not quite
just quickly bringing up the analysis
board if
white had one more move to take on a
fourth day draw because
wrong color corner with this bishop so
you need those
to match and if you could take on e4 you
just sit your king back in the corner
theoretical draw
knd5 says resign time sorry buddy
that's that and we have a new game we
have wesley with an eight
point lead yep danya eighteen and a half
minutes left i don't think these will be
the happiest 18 plus minutes of
young christophed his life no these yeah
no
definitely not and uh when it rains it
pours
i think that under different
circumstances you know maybe he could
have
pulled out a bullet come back we won't
rule anything out uh
you know the intrigue is possible until
the last second and we remind people
that a big portion of the prizes are
based on the actual result so there's a
lot on the line
uh but yeah it's just and and
one can only feel the pain these kinds
of matches you have no recovery time you
talked about this before
can't take a breath and that's part of
the fun but it's also part of the pain
when things don't go your way
absolutely and as you said the
prize fund there's three thousand
dollars to the winner of these
quarterfinal matchups plus three
thousand dollars split by win percentage
and right now wesley so he's getting a
heck of a lot of money
yeah he is that's what i'm noticing in
the confidence 52 seconds he's
every move is just increasing and
enriching the pressure it's incredible
he's trading off the queens if the
knight goes to b5 to avoid the queen
shirt e6 comes and you get pressure here
rook f1 the brook has to go to f8
and you take on a7 he's in flow and
you know that's a famous concept i think
in psychology coined by the most
unpronounceable
psychologist of all time but we just
feel it you know he's in the zone
one second per move increasing the
pressure and uh
and here comes the nigel short king walk
yep exactly
so i'm looking for him looking for this
king to run out here
due to trying to hold things together
with his knight
okay if you could play knight takes c5
that'd be a good move
right we talk about capturing our own
that's right
knight d4 to c5 and here comes the king
yup king e4 k85 sure as the sun will
rise
oh first he's got a setup
so now that i can't go back to e6
because of rook takes c6
it can't go to f5 to win h4 but i don't
think that
wesley's so worried about that no
going after the pawn back to d7
and finally dude all right all right
okay knight c5 is a threat so careful
now
i've had enough that's what he said and
by the way wessey's rating 3026 in
bullet
that's absolutely underrated yeah i
think he might just be a little bit
better
oh yeah i actually played him quite i
mean this he should be at least 3200
i mean it's weird to speak in those
terms all these ratings are
astronomically high but
this guy is uh he's insane well here
actually duda with a
massive defense it's a draw now oh
knight of an a4
no d check yes you both have the same
regulator
maybe practically oh yeah knight
and look at wesley that's the first time
i've seen him be upset about his
gameplay he was upset about the music
earlier right now
he's like how did i allow this fork and
now i'm down two pawns
yep and now it's over how much time is
that 15 minutes
for what will be seven games needed by
jkd
he's gotta win he's gotta give some
scholar mates i think wesley's known to
miss them once in a while
well maybe we'll see you know some
sacrificial play yeah we tend to see
some fireworks toward the end
when and that's fun
indeed and okay the e5 pawn is
just done working for check nice little
technique and there's nothing that white
can do here he's gonna go king h1 oh
oh look wes he's running out to laugh
that's why his hand over his face
yeah it's always funny because you never
see
gm's own super gms playing out until
checkmate
right every second matters though
there we go do it a wins one
seven to fourteen is our score and duda
the kind of face that
is like yeah this just ain't going my
way
and he's trying to go into the king's
gambit he's had enough of all the talk
about the queen's gambit so here
he's making bobby fischer proud and as
you see the odds to win the match
obviously
wesley's dancing head at the beginning
didn't look very good because smarter
chess thought that
duda would win the bullet portion but
then after wesley went on a tear
when all those three minute games of
course he's on top
right and um well dude with the
michaela moroney not impressed face the
universal symbol of like
meh but he's trying and i respect the
grind king's gambit now
going back old school yes
and the queen's coming to h4 there's
pawn on f7 the pawn f4 is falling
i kind of like this for white i do and i
think what i've learned is just don't
argue with smarter chess because smarter
chess
is not smarter than chess but smarter
than
me also i think it should be renamed
smarter than me
i don't like the name that's bad for
branding but
i see your point all right h6 played
bishop takes f4 kind of bishop e5
yeah but uh okay but now f3 becomes
possible trying to shatter the defenses
around white's king potentially
i'm into it knight g6 instead very
clinical again just keeping the f4 pawn
which is shutting down white's pieces
from
playing to their full potential wait why
don't you take the bishop first so he
could have taken the
queen of two and one right after f4
instead he allows the bishop to
rewrite itself this is bad the problem
sorry
go ahead no i didn't say anything uh no
you just made a very profound point i
wanted to want you to repeat bishop f4
queen g3 by the way
is an interesting tactic uh but i was
going to say like openings like the
queen's camp
like the king's gambit are you know
they're fun
but at a high level it's important to
understand they're just so well analyzed
that
it's just taken some of the intrigue out
of these openings some people sometimes
wonder
why don't they play those openings
anymore it's not out of a fundamental
lack of respect
for old school openings uh it's not that
the players don't want to have fun it's
just engines have
you know they've made a dent in some of
these speculative lines
they have indeed and you know just
not gonna work out for the most part one
thing that black would like here is a g7
to g5 to protect that pawn but you
would have to move the knight first oh
that's
it's so sad as a chess player when you
win material but you actually lose
material right back so right one in
exchange
but the rook is hitting well bishop look
at dude that's the game here up in
exchange
he bobbed a little bit do you see that
yeah he's vibing
bishop c3 or just take on g4 either one
yeah but rook fe-8 some chances i would
try to grant him a background potential
g1 rook is trapped look at that and he
sees it
and duda another win he's giving himself
a fighting chance 11 minutes
and it'll be a six point game
is there enough time for six games if he
plays very fast
remember remember you just need to be
able to start the last game start the
last game
basically it's doing five games right
which is still
difficult considering 11 minutes but
okay but he needs to start pre-moving
everything you can't start thinking
about how to convert this
you need to get down to business
yeah now i have mulan stuck in my head
so thank you for that let's
get down to business yeah let's not
sing that song in the middle of a chess
broadcast but it is stuck in my head
um i didn't see the new live-action
blonde did you 1966
and that's me okay go home you're
through
and uh dude is not through yet he's
trying his best
yeah he's he's having a better time i
wonder if the stress is kind of off
because
he knows that wesley is going to win
this match more or less
so he's a little bit more relaxed which
allows him to play better bullet
perhaps but on the same uh token here
wesley might be too relaxed
because he got to such a big score so
you never know how that's gonna play out
yeah you never do and uh now wesley
with a peaceful opening sort of
stabilizing all he really needs is a
draw to stem the tide and here we do see
duda look at the time he's moving fast
he recognizes the urgency
he hasn't lost hope and i actually love
that robert about these matches and the
fighting spirit displayed by these
players you never see them sort of
you know hanging just ah you know that's
that's it let's just uh
screw around now they're fighting to the
last drop of blood the problem is we
have a very symmetrical end game
wesley with a very savvy strategy
because he doesn't lose these end games
often
just typical wesley so just playing a
nice solid approach and i think black is
better
you have both your rooks out your king
is on f6 it seems like you're a little
bit ahead oh 94 isn't
that's a good call just to be cool stays
with the pawn just
imagine if he if he pre-moved 94
exactly okay we'll actually take d1 and
then go rook d2 don't laugh robert do
not laugh
ladies and gentlemen black is better
again black is much better winning a
pawn
he needs to go very fast he needs to win
this within 30 seconds
no that's not happening wesley also has
31 seconds remaining on his club
sometimes you make good points robert i
have to confess despite myself
yeah it's just you know there's a
doctor in spite of himself and there's a
donya in spite of himself here
so i i didn't get it to play don't worry
about it
so yeah so
it's upon before can you just capture it
yeah but this is not very
winnable is it with the spawn structure
has fixed it dude has to try to get his
king over
to d5 and c4 so
push the pawn to b3 get the king to c4
and win that the good news is
in this structure though danya is the g6
pawn isn't all that important because
look at how black's pawns remaining
pawns they stop
they stop the play right so you have
stolen a pawn but it's like you're not
even up a pawn on the king side
ladies gentlemen you took your seat
belts off thought we arrived at the
garage turned the car off
let's put those seat belts back on for a
second
and who's gonna wrap up the engine is it
gonna be you i'm right yeah
i always rub up the i'm the kind of rev
up the engine kind of person
you seem like it very high energy
needing to prove yourself
and just show everybody that you're in a
in my cruising in my ferrari
yep yeah totally ferrari kind of guy
hey you know i i hope that wesley's
listening the song fast car
by tracy chapman that'd be good for cars
by gary newman
you've you're plenty of options here
and dude is completely winning he's got
to go over the speed limit here though
i was done with the car references for
now wow he's only gonna be down
five but there will be
in rookies roommate pre-move it
yep wesley wesley doing by the way
anybody who's saying
ah why is wesley this is completely
within the rules and he's doing the
right thing
okay the time match clock is as
legitimately a part of the match as the
position on the board
he's doing what he can yeah and i know
that i saw mention of
pharaoh sayo's match against there is a
frugia
what fedocide did almost cost him the
match so
this is nothing new can you remind me he
made a draw in a position where he could
have just kept playing for a bunch of
moves
and still made the draw against alerissa
and then oh
did end up winning yup but it was a nail
biter so
it's not against the rules it is
actually not unsportsmanlike
it's perfectly reasonable thing to do
both players know the strategy
both players um have done been on both
sides of wins and losses in these
matches so
wesley is uh within his rights and
doing absolutely nothing wrong side no
exactly and he's also
just a classy person and then a true
professional so he's
he has a reputation and then he yeah
again well within his rights and and
here he's got a great position something
went terribly wrong dude with another
vienna king's gambit but this one went
terribly wrong he stacked upon but look
at wesley's pieces
sandwiched there in the center not
enough compensation
this not looking good oh it is not and
the knight can't be
down you you want to play g2 takes
imaginary piece on f3 that's the best
move
that's been the theme of the match
imagine if bonds could move diagonally
one square
without capturing every now and then
levitating over to f3
i'm here for it wait bishop g5 queen e5
that's a nice find by wesley
always these small tactics 94
yes sir nope defend the pawn for just so
surgical
this is not fun for this is no jkd
horrific position
but he tries footy county six to open up
the bishop
he needs to catch maybe wesley on some
pre-move
queen from my book queen d4 and hope
that the queen moves away from the g7
pawn that's your
only hope here well you know one of the
dirtiest tricks in the book
he did it whoa it's exactly c5 though
shutting down all hopes and dreams wait
a minute no 92
well that is a gnat that is just that is
beyond nasty
you can't even stop it like rook through
this queen one god
and it's over i was going to say one of
the dirtiest tricks in the book
so when let's say you play rook c8 and
your opponent has a rook on c1 right
so white takes rook takes c8 and he
assumes that you're going to recapture
the rook on c8 so he pre-moves
but instead you make another move for
example attacking the queen
right and so yeah i actually i think i
call this the
ferrous trap or the one random trap i
i'm gonna
hear for it i'm here for it it makes a
lot of sense
if you your opponent anticipates um
response or recapture
they pre-move something and so you make
a move like knight to b5 right
you've got to do it sparingly you got to
do once in a while
otherwise your opponent catches on and
it loses its effectiveness
agreed anyways i'm not sure why
if chess.com is paying me to talk about
dirty bullet tricks but
wesley he doesn't need them he has the
skill
and look at this blockade on e4 he's
going to put a bishop on e4
yeah then you move your king away and
play f4 and just open up this f file
against
chris exactly this is a good
illustration
of well first an attack but in general
double pawns right people are like oh
well they can't protect each other
another thing is if you capture with a
pawn in an adjacent file you leave
yourself with
isolated pawns so you can just threaten
upon and then try to open up the file
and rooks don't do well behind double
pawns because you can defend the first
one but not the second one so it's just
a
nightmare of a situation to have and
that's why duda gave up
in exchange that's a great insight and
um
rook h1 now wesley trying to prepare h5
although duda can keep things
shut uh with with the g5 and he's trying
to create chances himself queen f5
very resilient even until the very last
second of the match
okay don't play f3 the queen comes into
e2 and even here look at that
don't take on e5 because f2 is hanging
rook takes f4 threading both rook
h4 and rook f2 this looks like a
disaster
yeah wow what a turnaround but wait a
second there's some beautiful lines here
look up for queen d8 king g7 h6 dg3
exposing the discovery
i know what you were trying to do but
okay i don't know
what to do for black now 18 seconds he
doesn't do either
so what do you do here
because what did he do okay he took
he was afraid of that h6 move as he took
no that's not what you want
nope but but still i mean okay
black is not winning
no but i should know but i mean okay but
maybe somehow i'm in rook g5 okay
the rooks are too good here rook takes
h5 yeah this is
maybe not winning but it's definitely
good for white e3 it's rock h7
now it looks winning
for sure
all right yeah this is winning oh for
somebody e2 e2
severing the connection between the
rooks and wait a second why can't even
deliver perpetual robert rook g7 king f8
you can take and take it
off yeah wesley always has that trick in
the end
or rook g7 and rook f7 oh that was also
an option here i don't know why i'm
getting this excited about this game but
because you love
end games you love it i do a lot of end
games i always say i don't like them
on my stream but at my heart i i feel
like end games are
they're beautiful look at the perpetual
there's so much tactics and so much
under the surface
of an end game that looks completely
innocuous and that's amazing
and what speaking of amazing this
repetition here yeah it is amazing
it doesn't seem can escape not every day
yeah exactly
and we enter the final game of quite
possibly the final game of the match
with a minute left
on the clock and a six point lead
retained by wesley cell
wesley is a little bit good no i'm not
doing my wesley cell impression by the
way everybody
but wesley he'll move on to face the
winner of hikaru nakamura versus
vladimir putin sev
and hikaru of course is the favorite in
that matchup but i would
not be counting fedocide about out if i
were all of you in the audience here
fed us a very strong player whom hikaru
respects a lot and said as much in the
post-match interview
last time we saw him so that match will
determine who wesley
faces and if wassey does face hikaru
nakamura we saw hikar beat wesley in the
championship last year
i don't know it's always difficult for
anyone to play hikaru but wesley has the
style that if he's in tip-top shape
he really can go head-to-head with the
car maybe the bullet is where hikaru has
the biggest advantage but
yeah wesley will definitely make that a
very serious match and if
wins of course try to say if he has a
chance against anybody including magnus
and carol
yeah is a good friend of mine and i
you know i believe in him i think he's
an amazing player he's given a car
trouble but of course nakamura is
unmatched
across the board really and uh we'll see
i mean wesley will have to really bank
on the five and three minute portions
we see his prowess in the three-minute
portion particularly now in two matches
uh incredible yeah
well and looks like we have some
and we have some westlake is like what
yeah once he's gone he's like come on
this match is over i'm getting my cat
although if you think about it a draw
because some of the prize money is based
on win percentage draw helps
at the very least helps duda right so
not that they're really counting
yeah bills maybe they'll just agree one
in the spirit of the gentleman that they
are
i mean that's not the worst timing for
i've had some issues with uh
internet disconnections and timing
recently i think i know all about that
but
yep well we know how the match has
concluded
in wesley's show's favor we were just
talking about you know a potential
matchup with a car and nakamura we'll
see if a car can get through fedor save
donya it was really impressive by wesley
though
we really have to give him credit
because he was losing to start the match
he was down
two games in the five minute portion
before winning the last couple to even
that up and then the three minute wesley
soh
is the best player in the entire world
in three plus one time control you heard
it i mean the speed
confidence the ability to recover from a
loss especially as you pointed out
robert
the first two games judo went out of the
gate so strong
but the and also the opening preparation
legendary
let's not forget duda himself is an
opening juggernaut in so many games
wesley displayed
incredibly deep preparation across the
board in many different openings both
colors
as well as surgical filigree precision
in converting advantages in every time
control
he had the whole package today this is a
well deserved win we feel for duda
he tried his best he fought very hard
but today was not his day and
congratulations to wesley indeed we will
have the players on for a post-match
interview but for now enjoy the
finale of the primetime smackdown
between gotham chess
and hammer flagged when here i'm just
getting
annihilated oh man and people will see
this i will be
humiliated yeah it's a disaster
yeah it's it's really it's really not
good
man it's gonna wait it comes down to
okay
oh yeah you do this thing where you
don't resign right no
i never resigned that yeah it's a decent
strat wow
this is the it's a close it's close
match
are you nervous shut up
yeah so here i didn't put my knight on
h6
which i should have now this becomes a
bit uncomfortable
like this the other day on stream
oh you played against me on stream the
other day yeah remember toward the end
you like challenged yeah
it did not go well how did that go do
you remember what i said
right before sending you a challenge
uh love your stream a big fan from
norway
uh i don't believe that is what i said
okay what did you say
i believe i said something like play me
nude
i don't really i don't have recollection
of that um
but yeah i uh
i can definitely see you saying that
what was the score again
it i just like we played a bit you know
yeah it was interesting it was it was
competitive yeah
yeah i believe the score was
quite significant to my advantage
i i don't remember i'm sorry i
i think it was 6-1 positions also
resembled this one i should say
in in that match i'm liking my chances
yeah this is uh
oh you clutched it out you clutched it
out
let's go let's go
that's how you do it people
[Music]
after an excellent quarterfinal matchup
we have both players in the call wesley
and young christoph thanks for joining
us
wesley have to start with you
congratulations on what was a very
impressive performance and i must ask
you started off down
two points how did you write the footing
you know not only tie the score but then
go on to
really have one of the most impressive
performance ever in the three minute
time control
yeah thank you actually yeah i just uh
i started with half a point out of three
and uh i just took a deep breath
and tried to move on forget about the
past
and focus on the current game that's you
know with blitz it happens also quickly
and you have to focus on one game at a
time and and forget about what happened
in the past win or lose
yeah how do you keep that composure
though because a lot of people will go
on tilt but it seemed like you were
still pretty calm throughout yeah i just
take a deep breath try to play solidly
try to play what you know the best
uh try not to blunder anything if you
can make a couple of draws usually the
tilt will go away
try to play positions that you that you
are comfortable in and try to get
opening positions where you're happy and
don't take
unnecessary risks uh but of course
easier said than done and also the uh
if you're it depends also on your
opponent
yeah well ian joseph uh sorry that the
match should not go your way but
congrats on a very well played match
nonetheless uh from your perspective
what do you think contributed to the
turn around after the initial
uh great start in the five minute
portion
yeah i think that this neither game was
russia like
um i think i would play him but somehow
like i
couldn't have found a pincher and i
decided to go for his end game
and it was very like heartbreaking i
lost this one versus two
so yeah after that i mean it started
to go down here
[Music]
this game at all so yeah yeah and since
then i
started to definitely like i tried to
forget about it and to focus on
childhood
it wasn't yeah i just couldn't do it and
yeah he also played very well like my
special only three plus one
section i just couldn't like predict any
of his moves so
yeah that makes a lot of sense and one
question for you wesleyan congrats again
on
an amazing match uh do you sort of think
through
the strategy before the match in terms
of where you want to be after each
section where you consider yourself a
favorite or does that
is that not part of your preparation you
just decide to play one game at a time
how to what extent do you think that
through
yeah i mean it's very hard to predict
exactly what would happen before
but i think it's pretty obvious that jan
kristoff is a better bullet player than
me based on ratings
so i kind of needed to be ahead by
uh preferably two points before the
bullet
so i was keeping that in mind and uh
also i don't really want to be behind in
the five minute portion either
and uh so uh yeah i just have to keep in
mind that
hopefully i'll be up a game or two
before the bullet
but and then
because of my lead during the bullet
games i could kill time
in in many of the games and that worked
well
but definitely i'm sorry sorry i didn't
mean to cut you off how about ahead
yeah i was going to ask young kristoff
you know on your side of things when
when it wasn't going your way in the
three minute did you have a number in
mind that you needed to be down by
this many points to have a chance in the
bullet
yeah i actually lost control over the
score so
you know i was quite surprised to see
that this you know 25 or so
but yeah i'm
[Music]
yeah okay i just yeah i was blundering
vlogging every game
so it was once definitely like
you know how to keep the score and
yeah i mean yeah definitely i mean i
should have done something i mean but i
don't know what exactly
so yeah yeah but i must say also that it
was i knew it was going to be a very
tough match because i played yankers off
two years ago but he's improved a lot as
a player he's become more stable his
openings are better
and i knew he felt very comfortable in
unclear and complicated positions
so actually he was getting very good
position with this bishop g5
italian game so so i
i had to avoid that oh cos before the
match i wasn't
sure exactly if i'm going to get good
positions out the opening
but i was just trying to to get the feel
of where i'll get comfortable positions
and of course what happened the
three-minute portion was totally
unexpected for everyone yeah and
speaking of getting comfortable it seems
like your cat
is a very comfortable in your arms right
now wesley so
we all love your cat and i do have a
question for you because
were you listening to music during the
match
no i actually no i was thinking
okay that's right we thought you were
singing but we weren't sure if you also
listen to music so
you know what kind of music do you
listen to or were you singing to you
know help you out to the match
oh yeah funny i was listening to bg
yesterday
nice so the songs
[Music]
yeah but but but it's fine because i was
i knew i was tilting in the very
beginning of the match
so i just had to change the rhythm and i
had to
change the setting right away so i
figured
singing and talking to myself with the
microphone off
with microphone mute it won't hurt
anybody and it
it worked it made me feel more
comfortable then
just try to forget about the tilt yeah
that makes sense
and young chris you weren't listening to
anything right you were just playing
no music or anything yeah trying trying
to play good chances
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know it's weird like some
players are very distracted by music
well some players
like hiko i guess play better with music
or i'm like daniel
do you listen to music well sometimes
but i play worse but i still listen to
it because i'm
too addicted to music i know i'll play
badly regardless
well we're gonna let you two go but one
last question for you wesley
uh you will face the winner of hikaru
and uh
fedocev and you know we know your
history with hikaru
including the final of last year's
speedchest championship but
what are you going to do to get ready
for that match up or are you going to
wait to see who you play
uh yeah i have to wait to see who i play
first of all i think they play on
december 3rd right
something like that i haven't checked
the date
yeah yeah so first of all yeah we have
the
magnus the first magnus chester this
sunday
so it's going to be a longer time
control and i'm going to
play in that tournament that's gonna
take quite a bit
and uh we'll see what happens hikaru is
clearly the favorite in that match
and uh in any match unless against
magnus
he's the favorite so it's going to be
uh tough uh
yeah i don't uh really want to think
about hickory yet but i'm going to have
to play a lot of bullet games and
end it well that makes sense and in the
meantime
again you know chris i'm sorry the match
shouldn't go your way but we always love
having you in the field you
made it through a tough invitational
just to get here so
we're definitely proud of you many fans
out there who are supporting you and
wesley to you another great performance
another excellent
match and please say hi to your cat
for me uh you know zanzibar cute the cat
i love cats so uh we really appreciate
you joining us for the post office
interview
all right thank you yeah great match
yeah
there you heard it from the players it
was a tough match they really have great
respect for one another
and we're starting to have great respect
for javakir 40 because no this isn't a
repeated graphic this feed a master wins
the 75 dollar guess the move
every single time and dragon b70 looks
like a throne you've been kicked off it
you're in second with 50 bucks
and indian lad and grand master 25
and congrats again to lapree and ananth
sc for gaining some memberships to
chess.com
fantastic stuff good to see people
engaging uh with with the match and
speaking of matches we got so many more
coming up as we see these mouth-watering
names wesley
uh of course advances but vladimir
fetish have any car nakamura that is a
heavy
hitter matchup that we'll have on uh
december the third i think we said
that's what wesley said so yeah that's
the word on the street but we got some
guy
whose initials are mc that guy might
have something to say
about the proceedings of the sec as well
so so much stuff coming up ahead
certainly we have our remaining
quarterfinal matchups before we get into
semi's adventure the finals but donya
this was an excellent display of chess
from wesley so
as he said himself when he got down two
games he was trying just to
find his footing over the board get
positions that he felt comfortable in
and most importantly he did not want to
freak out and let the match get away
from him
he is amazing right the way he played
that match
leaves a lot to study honestly on just
how he was able to
outplay such a strong player like young
christoph duda
absolutely we talked about all of the
amazing skills that he displayed today
including but not limited to opening
preparation time management
and just presence of mind lack of tilts
he talked about some of it in the
post-game interview and
all of that came together in a nice
package a consummate professional
very classy person and a joy to watch
not to take anything away from
jkd who put up a tremendous fight but
wesley the deserved winner today robert
i would agree with that and you know he
plays so well that i feel stumped and
i'm always just calling his chest
amazing and
it's like well robert you're getting
repetitive but that's the type of
performances that wesley so gives us
he moves on to the semifinals his record
in the speed chess championship
is really something that you just have
to look at like that guy
only gets defeated by hikaru nakamura
and if you look at his match history
magnus hikaru those are the people who
have
taken them down so wesley he knows his
works cut out for him he calls a car the
favorite in
any matchup he plays except if he plays
magnus carlsen he has more chests to be
played
in longer time patrols and that
adjustment can be difficult too but
dania
enough about the players i want to thank
you for being my co-host today
i know we have our friendly ribbing but
at the end of the day
i'm always so thrilled that you join me
for the commentary
i have a great time i also learned quite
a bit from you so anyways
thanks for teaming up with me today i
wouldn't think of doing with anyone else
i always enjoy it robert you're awesome
and yeah ribbing aside
i always have a great time and you're a
big part of the reason why and the other
big part of the reason why is of course
the thousands and thousands of you who
were joining joining us throughout this
match a huge shout out
to everyone taking time out of their
busy tuesdays and watching this amazing
match by tuesday by tuesday you do mean
thursday right
thursday i can't even say this probably
i was thinking about title tuesday
and so it escaped my mind man but who
knows what day of the week it is anymore
it's times have changed haven't they i
quite literally just told you what day
of the week
it's thursday i know it's thursday yeah
no i disagree robin it's tuesday it's
actually
it's my my rules it's tuesday oh no no
this is the t it's the same okay anyways
we'll leave that for the next match but
all jokes aside an amazing match and
robert thanks to you and thanks to
everybody for
uh for watching yeah i definitely want
to thank all of our moderators our
producers behind the scenes making this
such a seamless broadcast you really
make it our lives so much better
by chatting with us it just becomes much
more enjoyable so
thank you once again for being a part of
the chess community and for
uh being a fan of chess.com and the
events that they
uh put on for you so on that note enjoy
the rest of your
thursday we will see you soon for more
chess action and more
from the speeches championship brought
to you by chess.com
give up that bishop on h6 potentially no
he keeps it bishop a6 though
okay so you can win in exchange for the
queen 65 gets the queens off
one blood on the queen you order the
queen
what does he think he doesn't take him
oh he missed it he's saying
oh my god that dude shakes his head has
wesley not seen it
he didn't see it was he didn't react
yeah no he didn't see it
[Music]
you